All right, listener, we're going to start with a little brain tease for us just to get us up on our feet and get nice and sharp for the chatter and the banter. What we're going to do, we're going to try a quick little podcast exercise. Here we go, ready, I'm going to start it out. Ready, S. We're going to start one more time. Still rolling? Here I go, I'm going to start.
好的，听众朋友们，我们先来做一个小小的脑筋急转弯，让我们活动活动筋骨，为之后的闲聊和互怼做好准备。接下来，我们要尝试一个非常短小的播客练习。准备好了吗，我要开始了。准备，S。我们要再来一次。还在录吗？我来了，我要开始了。
Ready? S. M. A. R. T. L Well, we're going to go again
准备好了吗？S。M。A。R。T。L 额，我们重来一次。
We're not really up to podcast It was your turn It was my turn No, but why were you pausing? I was scared I was going to get the wrong letter You want to write it out Write it out in front of you
我们真的不适合做播客。轮到你了。轮到我了。不对，你刚才为什么停顿？我怕自己说错字母。你想把它写下来吗？写在你的面前。
You don't know how to spell smartless In this point we're like a thousand episodes Here we go, I'm going to start again Here we go in three two one ready S M A R
你竟然不知道 smartless 怎么拼。到这时候我们都录了一千集了。好了，我要重新开始了。我们准备三、二、一，开始，S、M、A、R。
T L E S I almost made it Welcome to smartless I mean We limp across a finish line.
T、L、E、S。我差点就成功了。欢迎来到 smartless。我是说，我们简直是连滚带爬地冲过了终点线。
No wonder that's the title. You know, Will, it's really, Will, it's odd to see you this morning. Maple for the un-initiated listener. That's my youngest daughter. She's 13. She's got some friends that were talking about Arrested Development, so she said to me, well, I'd like to see Arrested Development. She hasn't really seen it.
难怪节目叫这个名。你知道吗，威尔，今天看到你真的很奇怪，威尔。枫树，对于还不了解的听众解释一下。那是我的小女儿。她13岁了。她有些朋友在讨论《发展受阻》，所以她对我说，嗯，我想看《发展受阻》。她其实还没怎么看过。
Oh, wow. Shut up, Sean. I should watch it with her. Yeah, no. So I was watching Arrested last night, season one, episode 3, 4, and 5. I mean, there he is. Look at him. Look at this.
哦，哇。闭嘴，肖恩。我应该陪她一起看。对，没错。所以我昨晚在看《发展受阻》第一季的第3、4、5集。你看，他就在那儿。快看他。看看这个。
There's Job right there. I'm a little star-struck. Boy, we were such little kitties. It was 25 years ago. I know, dude. It's crazy. Isn't that amazing? We look very different.
GOB就在那儿。我有点追星的感觉了。天哪，我们那时候真是小可爱。那是25年前的事了。我知道，老兄。太疯狂了。是不是很神奇？我们看起来很不一样。
We all look very different. I know. And it's, Sean, has no point of reference, but it's other than his memory. By the way, Jason, he also knew us at the time we were on the show, too. So we were watching then. I know. This was during the time we were watching Will and Grace. Sure.
我们看起来都非常不一样。我知道。而且，肖恩，他除了自己的记忆之外，根本没有参照物。顺便说一句，杰森，他认识我们的时候，我们也在拍那部剧。所以我们当时也在看。我知道。那是我们正在看《威尔和格蕾丝》的时期。没错。
One of us was actually on Will and Grace. I went on. I went on. No, I know. We loved it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, how about that? Wait, what does it feel like, you guys, 25 years ago?
我们其中一个人实际上还出演了《威尔和格蕾丝》。我客串过。我客串过。不，我知道。我们太喜欢了。对，对，对，对。话说回来，你们觉得25年前是怎样一种感觉？
Doesn't it feel like just a week ago? It does. Yes and no. 25 years is pretty short at this age. Yeah. Yeah, it's pretty weird. So, Shawnee, you're still in London. Sean, what's the elevator update?
是不是感觉就像一个星期前？确实。既是又不是。在这个年纪，25年其实很短暂。对。对，挺诡异的。所以，肖尼，你还在伦敦。肖恩，电梯最新情况怎么样了？
Sorry, I haven't asked in a while, so how are we doing? We okay? Well, when Jason came, it was broken the day before he came, and then they fixed it. And I'll have you know during. the, what is it, what was they there, four days? Yeah. Four days? Didn't ride the elevator once on purpose.
抱歉，我有一段时间没问了，所以现在情况怎么样？我们还好吗？嗯，杰森来的时候，在他来的前一天电梯就坏了，然后他们修好了。而且我得告诉你们，在他们呆的那几天里，是什么来着，他们呆了几天？对。几天？一次电梯都没坐过，我是故意的。
I got through. Because of that. No, no, no. I just, I was like, no, I can do these stairs. I'm going to, I'm going to pretend that I'm back in the olden days. That's right. That's right. Yeah, this thing was built, this townhouse was built in 1770.
我挺过来了。因为那个。不，不，不。我只是觉得，不，我可以走这些楼梯。我要，我要假装我回到了过去的好日子。没错。没错。是的，这栋房子是1770年建造的。
Crikey. Wow, that's Ozzy. Elevator, too. No. And Willie, you're still in, you're just slogging it out there and blue collar long. island you know yeah yeah yeah this put in the air is it no air conditioning and uh sweeping the steps i mean you know i mean this is this is such a for me it's such a i'm getting whiplash because like i'm normally i'd be in the in the ocean right now i'm playing golf with beerman tomorrow right why why
天哪。哇，那是澳洲口音吗？还有电梯。没有。威利，你还是在长岛那蓝领阶层苦苦挣扎，你知道的，对啊对啊，没有空调，还要扫台阶。我的意思是，这对我来说简直太……我都有点颈椎扭伤了，因为我平时现在本应该在海里，我明天还要跟别尔曼打高尔夫呢，对吧？为什么，为什么？
what do you mean what do you mean just because i'm having to do because i'm doing this no because i I had to come downstairs to do this. Oh, sorry about that. So sorry to interrupt. Hey, how has golf been? I'm going to actually hit balls today for the first time in over eight months, probably. Wow.
你什么意思，你什么意思？就因为我不得不……因为我在做这个？不，因为我得下楼来做这个。哦，真抱歉。真不好意思打扰你。嘿，你最近高尔夫打得怎么样？我今天大概是八个多月以来第一次去击球。哇。
I just want to say this. One of my favorite things about J.B., one of the many, many things that I love about him, is, A, his, when he's playing golf, he's playing golf. And when he's not, he's really not playing. Like, he won't go to all. But, Jason, what's funny is the number of people who are aware of it, and I get so much,
我只想说这个。我最喜欢JB的一点，或者说我爱他的很多很多优点之一，就是，第一，当他在打高尔夫时，他就是在打高尔夫。而当他不打的时候，他是真的不打。比如，他根本不会去……但是，杰森，有趣的是，有多少人关注这件事，我听到了太多……
On the fringes of like, hey, I get taxed, like, is Jason playing again? Is he started yet? Like, everybody knows that when it starts, it's going to be an avalanche. So I can tell you. You know what else it is? It's people, people miss me, Will. They miss, there's a big hole in their lives. And they want it on, it can be filled again.
在边缘地带听到各种声音，比如，嘿，我被打听了，就像，杰森又开始打球了吗？他开始了吗？每个人都知道只要他一开始，就会一发不可收拾。所以我可以告诉你。你知道这还说明什么吗？说明人们，人们想念我，威尔。他们想念……他们的生活中有一个巨大的空洞。他们希望它能再次被填满。
Yeah, you're right. They want that, you're right, they want that hole. They want that asshole, that hole back. It's a hole. It's a hole that they want back. Has your game, your game must be good enough where you haven't, you haven't given up the game. No, it's actually, I didn't play for a little bit
是的，你说得对。他们想要那个，你说的对，他们想要那个空洞。他们想要那个混蛋，那个空洞回来。那是一个空洞。这是一个他们想要找回的空洞。你的球技，你的球技一定好到你还没有，还没有放弃这项运动。不，其实，我有一小段时间没打，
and it's actually been pretty good recently, to be honest. Oh, God bless. Yeah. I mean, I don't know if our audience wants to hear I'm hitting irons, but, you know. No, of course. You're hitting irons, no woods? I'm hitting irons well.
但老实说，最近其实打得相当不错。哦，上帝保佑。对。我是说，我不知道我们的听众想不想听我打铁杆，但是，你知道的。不，当然。你在打铁杆，没有用木杆？我铁杆打得很好。
Are you? Yeah, it's been good. Yeah, it's been good. Sorry about that. I said, I preemptively said sorry. I haven't seen you guys for a couple of. We got a classy guess I can tell by Sean's embarrassment. No, not at all.
是吗？对，一直挺好的。对，一直挺好的。抱歉啊。我说，我提前道了个歉。我好久没见你们了。我们来了一位很有品位的嘉宾，我从肖恩的尴尬中就能看出来。不，一点也不。
Is this your guest, Sean? No, I wanted to share with Will what Jason was kind of blown away when I went for a walk with me, Jason Franny, and we walked past Buckingham Palace and I asked a genuine question if the family actually lived in the palace. And I was, I'm, but the point is... He wanted to know if it was just a tourist stuff.
这是你的嘉宾吗，肖恩？不，我想跟威尔分享一下，当杰森和我一起散步时，杰森有多震惊。我和弗兰妮散步，路过了白金汉宫，我认真地问了一句王室成员是不是真的住在宫里。而我当时，我是说重点是……他想知道那是不是只是个旅游景点。
That's what I thought it was. That size place. all the infrastructure in and around it and everything just for people to walk by and look through the gates right because I thought it like the Mona Lisa like I don't think the Mona Lisa's the real Mona Lisa is hanging I think that's gotta be like it sure is ding dong and also like why would they
我是这么想的。那么大个地方，周围所有的基础设施和一切，难道仅仅是为了让人们走过并透过大门往里看吗？对，因为我觉得就像蒙娜丽莎一样，我不觉得蒙娜丽莎挂着的是真的蒙娜丽莎，我觉得那肯定得是……真是个大笨蛋。而且还有就是，为什么他们……
if it was for tourists then they'd let them in if nobody's true and I looked at him like he was you know the kind of the kind of doorknob that would say hey boy beetles is spelled B-E-A-T I never did. I had a lot of people backing me up on that.
如果是给游客准备的，那他们就会放人进去了，如果没人……真的。我看着他，就像看那种……那种连“披头士乐队”的“披头士”怎么拼都会拼错的笨蛋。我从来没那样过。有很多人支持我呢。
They still live there. Of course, they've got other castles that they live in sometimes too, but that's home for them. He's like, oh, really? I go, yeah, you dumb ass. Two hours later, he pulls me aside in privacy and goes, hey, no, seriously,
他们确实住在那里。当然，他们有时也住在其他城堡里，但那里对他们来说就是家。他当时就说：“哦，真的吗？”我说：“对啊，你这个大笨蛋。”两小时后，他把我拉到一边私下说：“嘿，说真的，他们还住在那里吗？”我说：“对啊，你他妈的大笨蛋。”我不想让别人听到。你想了两个小时？
do they still live there? I'm like, yeah, you fucking dumbass. I didn't want anybody else to hear me. Been thinking about it. Yeah, for two hours. Like, wow, they really lived there. You know what? Next time,
对，想了两个小时。心想，哇，他们居然真的住在那里。你知道吗？下次，
yourself the embarrassment of us chewing you out and just look it out. Turn on the Google machine. I know I was got, I know, I had it in my brain that I needed to Google it later. But is there most of the memory on your phone taken up by a candy crush? Is that the problem that Google that they throttled your Google down? What's my data?
省得我们把你数落一顿，自己去查一下吧。打开谷歌机器。我知道我被难住了，我知道，我脑子里想着回头得用谷歌查一下。但是你手机里的大部分内存都被糖果粉碎传奇占满了吗？这就是问题所在吗？所以他们限制了你的谷歌流量？我的流量怎么了？
No, all right. We haven't done a record for a couple weeks. I know, it's so fun to see you guys. I know, it's really fun to see you. You look great. I miss you guys so much. I miss you, too. And then you guys texted me a really nice text and said that we're here, Jason was very sweet and squished and said, we're here and we're thinking about you, we're talking about you,
不，好吧。我们已经好几周没录节目了。我知道，见到你们太开心了。我知道，见到你们真高兴。你气色真好。我太想念你们了。我也想你们。然后你们俩给我发了一条非常温馨的信息，说我们在这里，杰森非常贴心、亲昵地写道：“我们在这里，我们在想你，我们在谈论你，我们想念你。”
we miss you. Yes. No response. And I know. Well, I was like, I almost cried. It was so moving. And then what else? Then I sent you another. I sent you a little link to a fun pair of shoes that we all thought that you'd actually really look good at. About three days later. Well, you know, I'm on
没错。没有任何回复。我知道。嗯，我当时……我差点哭了。太感人了。然后还有什么？然后我又给你发了另一个。我给你发了一个有趣的鞋子链接，我们都觉得你穿起来肯定会很好看。大约三天后。好吧，你知道，我……
you're not that busy and I know that phone is attached to your little holster right next to your side arm. You're always on the phone. Why do I take three days to get a response? I don't text you enough. No, Will's not a super fast text her back.
你其实没那么忙，我知道那部手机就别在紧挨着你配枪的那个小枪套上。你随时都在玩手机。为什么我花天才得到回复？我给你发的信息还不够多。不，威尔不是那种回信息特别快的人。
I'm not. Because he's busy doing... No, when I'm out here, I do try to leave my phone, put my phone down as much as I can. Riley? Oh, dude. Oh, Riley. I haven't heard Riley in a while.
我确实不是。因为他忙着做……不，当我在外面的时候，我确实尽量不碰手机，能放下手机就尽量放下。莱利？哦，老兄。哦，莱利。我好久没听到莱利的声音了。
All right, guys, before we get to the guests, can I just... Oh, no. Yeah, let's remind everybody our, we're very excited about this. Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes. We are bringing SmartList to one of the most iconic spots in the world. And no, we're not talking about Sean Serial Bowl. We're talking about the Hollywood Bowl.
好吧，各位，在我们请出嘉宾之前，我能不能……哦，不。对，让我们提醒大家，我们对此感到非常兴奋。哦，对，对，对，对。我们要把 SmartList 带到世界上最具标志性的场所之一。不，我们说的不是肖恩的麦片碗。我们说的是好莱坞碗。
Jason, Jason. So if you're in that Hollywood area, when is it? When is it? This fall, you know when it is. You're so helpful the way you toss to me. This fall, Saturday, November 15th, here in Los Angeles, if you're in the area, Saturday, November 15th. And when did tickets go on sale then?
杰森，杰森。所以如果你在好莱坞地区，什么时候？什么时候？今年秋天，你知道是什么时候。你把话题抛给我的方式真是太贴心了。今年秋天，11月15日星期六，就在洛杉矶，如果你在附近的话，11月15日星期六。那门票什么时候开始发售呢？
The tickets, God, again, really will. Friday, September 12th, 10 a.m. Pacific time. Tickets go on sale. Friday, September 12th. Come to get live. Yeah, before Jason's bedtime, okay. Yeah, before I go to bed. Before I can sleep on stage.
门票，天哪，真的又是这样，威尔。9月12日星期五，太平洋时间上午10点。门票开始发售。9月12日星期五。来看现场秀吧。对，在杰森睡觉之前，好吧。对，在我睡觉之前。在我可以在舞台上睡觉之前。
It's fun to see me sleep. What are some of the things you think we can see? I think that we're going to have some guests. We're going to have a guest. I'm going to have a guest. Sean does not get a guest. No, but I'll bring a bowl of cereal Just to mess, Sean, close the loop on the little...
看我睡觉很有趣。你觉得我们能看到什么？我觉得我们会有一些嘉宾。我们会有一位嘉宾。我会有一位嘉宾。肖恩没有嘉宾。不，不过我会带一碗麦片。为了恶搞一下，肖恩，把那个小悬念做个了结……
That's, what a loop closer you are. You've been closing loops since 1970. Not just fruit loops, okay? All right, so listen, so once again, that's this fall at the Hollywood Bowl, November 15th, you can start getting tickets on September 12th. And our listeners have a chance to get tickets first, right? Our presale begins Tuesday, September 9th.
你真是一个善于首尾呼应的人啊。你从1970年就开始做首尾呼应了。不仅仅是水果麦片，好吗？好了，听着，再次强调，就在今年秋天的11月15日好莱坞碗，你可以在9月12日开始购买门票。我们的听众有机会最先买到门票，对吧？我们的预售将于9月9日星期二开始。
September 9th. Yeah, at 10 a.m. Pacific time, visit smartlist.com slash live and enter our code, and you guessed it. It's Tracy, T-R-A-C-E-Y for First Access. That's our listeners with a pre-sale chance. September 9th, 10 a.m., smartlist.com slash live. Guys, this is exciting.
9月9日。是的，太平洋时间上午10点，访问 smartlist.com 斜杠 live 并输入我们的密码，你猜对了。就是 Tracy，字母是 T-R-A-C-E-Y，即可获得优先购票权。这是留给我们的听众的预售机会。9月9日上午10点，smartlist.com 斜杠 live。伙计们，这太令人兴奋了。
Friday 12th. And you can't, can you tell me who your guests are? No. No, it's supposed to be a surprise, ding-dong. It's a surprise. It's going to be surprise to the audience, too, for the first time, right? Well, I guess these live shows, it's not the first time. But, Jay, B, you were just at the bowl, too, right?
12日星期五。那你能不能，你能告诉我你们的嘉宾是谁吗？不能。不能，这本该是个惊喜，大笨蛋。这是一个惊喜。对观众来说也将是第一次听到，对吧？好吧，我猜这些现场演出，这并不是第一次。不过，JB，你刚才也在好莱坞碗，对吧？
I was just at the bowl watching some classical music. with Amanda and the girls, and they hated me for, yeah, they got some nice eye rest. But Granddad was really enjoying it. I had a good time. Anyway, but we're going to liven things up there on Saturday, November 15th.
我刚才就在好莱坞碗听古典音乐，和阿曼达还有女孩们一起，他们恨死我了，因为，是的，他们好好休息了一下眼睛。但爷爷真的很享受。我度过了一段美好的时光。不管怎样，我们将在11月15日星期六让那里的气氛活跃起来。
So get your tickets starting on the 12th of September or pre-sale on the 9th. It's going to be brilliant. It's going to be brilliant. Okay, let's get to our guests. I'm glad on coming over to see. To see it. All right, here comes our guest.
所以请从9月12日开始买票，或者9月9日参与预售。这一定会非常精彩。一定会非常精彩。好了，我们来请出我们的嘉宾。我很高兴能看到她来。来看她。好了，我们的嘉宾来了。
Guests, our guest. By the way, circling back to Google, here's somebody you don't have to Google. Because you know what? She's the CEO of Google? Could you imagine? No, she's better than that. She's bigger than that.
嘉宾，我们的嘉宾。顺便说一句，回到谷歌的话题，这位是你不必用谷歌搜索的人。因为你知道吗？她是谷歌的CEO？你能想象吗？不，她比那还要好。她比那更伟大。
She's amazing. Bigger than Google? Yeah. Jesus Christ. She's, yeah, I'm a little intimidated by her. Buckle up. She's one of those people who makes you wake up, quit complaining, get your shit together.
她太棒了。比谷歌还伟大？是的。天呐。她，是的，我对她有点敬畏。系好安全带。她是那种能让你猛然惊醒、停止抱怨、把生活过好的人。
No? Back in college, she proposed to her boyfriend, they got married, they're still together, behind her signature black-rimmed glasses. She's a podcast powerhouse, a full-blown mogul, and the number one best-selling author in the world right now. Please welcome to five-second queen. That's it. Five-second queen herself, Mel Let's us.
不是吗？还在大学时，她就向男友求婚了，他们结了婚，至今仍在一起，戴着标志性的黑框眼镜。她是一位播客 powerhouse，一位名副其实的大亨，也是目前全球排名第一的畅销书作家。请欢迎“五秒女王”登场。就是这样。“五秒女王”本人，梅尔·罗宾斯。
Oh, my God. You said my name. Oh, my God. I lose. Like, these fucking losers are going to spend 50 minutes figuring out who this is, and they never guess it's me. I would just shrink. Can you believe these fucking losers? I was thinking the same thing about these fucking losers.
哦，天哪。你念了我的名字。哦，天哪。我输了。就像，这群他妈的失败者要花50分钟来猜这人是谁，而他们永远也猜不到是我。我简直要无语了。你们能相信这群他妈的失败者吗？我刚才也在想这群他妈的失败者。
We're on the same. I'm not in that. I'm separate from that. But thank you. You're welcome. And you know, I got news for you guys. Sean called me. He's sick of your bullshit.
我们是一伙的。我可不跟他们一伙。我跟他们不一样。不过谢谢你们。不客气。而且我告诉你们一个消息。肖恩给我打过电话。他受够你们的废话了。
He can't change you. Are you leaving the show, Sean? Yes, this is an intervention. This is the transition. Mel, you're taking over for Sean Robbins. She's adopted me. I'm Sean Robbins. Oh, good luck.
他改变不了你。你要退出节目了吗，西恩？是的，这是一场干预。这是过渡期。梅尔，你来接替西恩·罗宾斯。她收养了我。我是西恩·罗宾斯。哦，祝你好运。
Good luck having them. Me and Robin. What an honor to have you on the show, Mel. Well, this is very, very nice if you're slumming it with us, you know? I know, I honestly was blown away because I know one of the criteria is you have to guess who the guest is. And I thought, oh, well, unless Sean says she's constantly ahead of us on the rankings in the podcast charts, you probably will. That is true. Who's looking?
祝你们好运。我和罗宾。很荣幸你能来节目，梅尔。好吧，你能屈尊和我们一起聊聊，这真是太好了，你知道吗？我知道，说实话我惊呆了，因为我知道其中一个标准是你得猜出嘉宾是谁。我想，哦，好吧，除非西恩说你在播客排行榜上的排名一直排在我们前面，否则你很可能会猜到。确实如此。谁在看？
Who's looking? That came up. I was just discussing you last week with some fancy folks. And they were singing your praises. and they were telling me about the whole let-them thing. And so I'm very eager to hear about... Yes, I can't wait for you guys to hear about it. Yeah, come on.
谁在看？这事提到了。我上周刚和一些时髦人士讨论过你。他们对你赞不绝口。他们跟我讲了“随他们去”的整套理论。所以我非常渴望听到……是的，我等不及让你们听听了。对，快说吧。
I like the let-them thing, too. Oh, there is behind you. Well, do this first, Mel. If you don't mind jumping in, first of all, thanks for being on here. A huge fan. I love how you speak, what you speak about, how you motivate me, how you motivate everybody.
我也挺喜欢“随他们去”这套理论的。哦，你身后有东西。好吧，梅尔，先做这个。如果你不介意的话，首先，谢谢你来到这里。我是你的超级粉丝。我喜欢你的言谈，你谈论的话题，你如何激励我，如何激励每一个人。
Like, it's, I can't get enough of it. I really kind of thrive off of it. This is you motivated. No shower. I look fantastic. But Mel, can you first talk before we get to let them, which I love, and I can't wait for you to tell Jason what that is and Will. What about the five-second rule?
就好像，我怎么都看不够。我真的有点靠这个汲取能量。这就是被激励的你。没洗澡。我看起来棒极了。不过梅尔，在我们聊到我超喜欢的“随他们去”之前，你能不能先跟杰森和威尔讲讲？“五秒法则”是怎么回事？
Can you just go over the five-second rule? Because for people who don't know, it sounds like obviously what you do when you drop the food on the floor and blah-blah. Well, it is kind of like that. So, you know, I think the first thing to understand is that everything that I talk about, I learned the hard way by screwing up my own life. And I don't think any of us wake up in the morning. Well, Will might.
你能顺便讲讲五秒法则吗？因为对不知道的人来说，这听起来显然就像食物掉到地上时你做的那种事，巴拉巴拉的。嗯，确实有点像那样。所以，你知道的，首先要明白的是，我谈论的一切，都是我自己把生活搞砸后通过惨痛教训学到的。而且我觉得我们谁也不会在早上醒来。好吧，威尔可能会。
But most of us don't wake up in the morning and go, you know what I'm going to do today. Today I'm going to fuck up my life. I think I'm going to drink too much and lie to people and lose my job. What ends up happening to most of us is over time, you spend too much time thinking about what you need to do and not doing what you need to do. And I found myself in a situation when I was 41 years old, three kids under the age of 10 where my husband had gone into the restaurant business. Right. Lost almost a million bucks. Oh yeah. Like complete idiots. We secured it with our life savings. And the restaurant business was great until 2008 hit. And like everybody else, the world turns upside down, and we found ourselves 800 grand in debt. The liens hit the house. I lose my job.
但我们大多数人早上醒来时不会想，你知道我今天要干嘛吗。我主要打算今天把生活给搞砸。我想我今天要多喝点酒，对别人撒谎，然后丢掉工作。我们大多数人最终发现的是，随着时间推移，你花了太多时间思考你需要做什么，却没有去做你需要做的事。我发现自己陷入了一种境地，当时我41岁，有三个10岁以下的孩子，我丈夫去搞餐饮生意了。没错。亏了将近一百万美元。哦，是的。就像两个十足的笨蛋。我们用全部积蓄做了抵押。餐饮生意本来挺好，直到2008年经济危机爆发。跟其他人一样，世界天翻地覆，我们发现自己背上了80万的债务。房屋留置权找上门来。我丢了工作。
And I couldn't get myself out of bed. And let's be honest, getting out of bed is a relatively easy thing to do when you think about the mechanics. I mean, by the time you're 41 years old, you've done it for 41 years. Right. But the simplest things in life can seem impossible when you're overwhelmed or stressed out or anxious or you have so many problems. Or depressed or whatever.
我根本起不了床。老实说，从机制上讲，起床其实是一件相对容易的事。我的意思是，等你到了41岁，这事你已经干了41年了。没错。但当你不知所措、压力山大、焦虑不安或者面临成堆的问题时，生活中最简单的事也会变得不可能完成。或者抑郁，诸如此类。
And so I just found myself in the situation where I would literally wake up every morning and stare at the ceiling and basically be like, I hate my life, I hate my husband, I don't know how I got here, we're fucked. and the more I thought about the problems, the more I felt like a human pot roast marinating in bed. And it became harder and harder to get out of bed. And, you know, honestly, I was literally, I knew what to do. And I think this is one of the biggest things about life. That life is simple. We just seem to make it very complicated.
所以我就发现自己陷入了这样一种境地：我字面意义上每天早上醒来盯着天花板，基本上心里想的就是，我恨我的生活，我恨我丈夫，我不知道我是怎么落到这田地的，我们完蛋了。我对这些问题想得越多，就越觉得自己像个躺在床上腌制的人类肉饼。起床变得越来越难。而且，说实话，我其实知道该怎么做。我觉得这是关于人生的最大真理之一。人生其实很简单。是我们自己把它搞得无比复杂。
Yeah. You can know what to do in any situation. And you guys talk about the Google. Just go to Google or that chat, GTP thing, and put in whatever it is that you want, and it'll spit out what you need to do, making yourself do it is what feels impossible. And so one night, I was watching TV.
对。你在任何情况下都知道该做什么。你们也经常讨论谷歌。直接上谷歌或者那个叫什么ChatGPT的东西，输入你想了解的任何内容，它就会吐出你需要做的事，而逼自己去执行才感觉是不可能完成的。所以有一天晚上，我在看电视。
It was Monday night in February 2008. And you literally are one decision away from a different life. That is the heart of what I talk about, the power of your decisions. And I was giving myself that pep talk. You know, when you, I don't know if you guys have ever, you can give each other pep talks. When you're giving one to yourself, you're kind of screwed. Where you're like, all right, that's it.
那是2008年2月的一个星期一晚上。你离另一种生活真的只差一个决定。这就是我所讲的核心，也就是你决定的力量。当时我正在对自己进行一番打气。你知道的，当你……我不知道你们有没有过，你们可以互相打气。当你给自己打气时，你基本上就完蛋了。就是那种你对自己说，好吧，就是这样。
Tomorrow, it's the new you woman. You've got to pull your shit. together. You got to stop being an asshole to Chris. You got to put down the alcohol. You got to get those kids on the bus. By God, you got to get a job. You got to open the bills that have been piling up for six months. And when that alarm rings,
明天，迎接全新的自己。你得振作起来。你得停止对克里斯混蛋。你得戒酒。你得把那些孩子送上校车。老天，你得去找份工作。你得拆开那些堆了六个月的账单。当闹钟响起时，
you can't lay there and marinate in your fears and hit the snooze button six times. You woman have got to get out of bed. And honest to God, a rocket ship launched across the television screen. It was probably like at the end of a smartless mobile commercial. You know, like launch right in there.
你不能躺在那里任由恐惧折磨自己，还按六次贪睡按钮。你必须起床。说实话，电视屏幕上划过了一艘火箭。那可能就像某个手机广告的结尾。你知道的，就像直接在那里发射一样。
No, but it's not a bad idea, though. Right? I steal it. Take it. Just write that down. Take it. I steal it is my idea. It is when you claim it like that. So I literally thought, oh my God, it's a sign from God.
不，但这主意其实不错。对吧？我偷了。拿去用吧。把它记下来。拿去用吧。我偷了就是我的主意。你这么说它就成你的了。所以我当时真的想，哦天哪，这是上帝的旨意。
That's it, tomorrow morning. What, just a rocket on the TV? On the TV? Is that what you're talking about? Yeah, well, it was probably the four bourbon Manhattan's I had that gave me that idea because I was kind of stupid, but I was drinking a lot back then. And so the next morning, Tuesday morning, the alarm rings. and here's the fatal mistake everybody makes.
就这样，明天早上。什么，电视里出现个火箭？在电视里？这就是你说的？对，好吧，那可能是我喝了四个波旁曼哈顿才让我有了这个想法，因为我当时脑子有点笨，不过那时候我确实喝了很多酒。所以第二天早上，星期二早上，闹钟响了。而每个人犯的致命错误来了。
There is this moment where you know what you should do. You should speak up, you should start the damn thing, you should quit the job, you should end the relationship, you should go to the gym. But instead of doing it, you stop and think about how you feel about doing it. And within five seconds flat in that hesitation, you literally switch gears in your brain.
有那么一瞬间，你知道自己该做什么。你应该大声说出来，你应该开始那该死的事业，你应该辞掉工作，你应该结束这段关系，你应该去健身房。但你没有去做，而是停下来，开始琢磨自己对这事的感受。就在那短短五秒钟的犹豫中，你的大脑 literalmente（字面意义上）换挡了。
I didn't know this at the time I do now. But the longer you think about it, the less likely you're going to do it. And in about five seconds, you lose all motivation. And your whole life plays out in this five-second window. And isn't there science to this, too, right? Tons of science. I mean, now I know the science. I didn't know it then.
我当时不知道，但现在知道了。你对它想得越多，去做的可能性就越小。大约五秒钟内，你就会失去所有的动力。你的一生其实就在这五秒钟的窗口期内展开。这背后其实也是有科学依据的，对吧？大量的科学依据。我的意思是，我现在懂科学了。我当时可不懂。宿醉、醒来面对如噩梦般的生活以及逃避的习惯。
Then I was just hung over, waking up to a life that was a nightmare and habits of avoidance. What was the thing you saw at night on TV? It wasn't literally a rocket being launched. It was a rocket ship, but at the end of a commercial, it was like launched, and I was so drunk. I was like, oh my God, it's God. Okay, I'll get out of bed. I'll launch myself out of bed so fast. I'll move like a rocket.
你晚上在电视上看到的是什么东西？并不是真的发射了一艘火箭。是一艘火箭，但那是在广告的末尾，就像发射一样，我当时喝得烂醉。我就想，哦天哪，上帝啊。好吧，我要起床。我要以火箭般的速度冲下床。
I won't be in there when the anxiety and the depression hits. I'm going to move. You took it as a metaphor. You took it to heart and it stayed with you the next morning and up you went. Yep.
当焦虑和抑郁袭来时，我绝不躺在那里。我要动起来。你把它当成了一个比喻。你把它记在心里，第二天早上它一直伴随着你，然后你就起来了。是的。
Well, I counted backwards and that's the person. What would have happened if you'd seen an image of a sinking ship? Oh, God. Right there. Done. We're out. We're just going to clock out right now.
好吧，我是倒数计时的，这就是诀窍。如果你看到的是一艘沉船的图像会发生什么？哦，天哪。当场。结束。我们直接收工。
Just for our listener. Or just the flaming Hindenburg. Yes. Yes. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah, but the thing is, Jason, very astute point, you have to count backwards. Okay. Okay. It's not just moving in five seconds. The counting backwards is critical. What researchers call it. Like a launch. Yes. Five, four, three, two, one. You have to count backwards. It doesn't work if you count up. Okay.
就为了我们的听众。或者干脆是着火的兴登堡号飞艇。对。对。没错。没错。是的，但关键是，杰森，你这个观点非常敏锐，你必须倒计时。好吧。好吧。不仅仅是在五秒钟内动起来。倒计时至关重要。研究人员称之为。就像发射一样。对。五，四，三，二，一。你必须倒计时。正着数可不管用。好吧。
One, two, three, four, five doesn't work because you've been saying that ever since you learned how to count in whatever language you learned how to count. When you count backwards, you have to focus for a moment. And that brings your prefrontal cortex online, which is the part of the brain that helps you make decisions. It's the part of the brain that helps you learn new behavior. It's the part of the brain that you need to use if you're going to lock in new habits. And I had a habit of just hitting the snooze button
一、二、三、四、五不管用，因为自从你学会数数以来，无论你用什么语言学会数数，你一直都在这么数。当你倒计时的时候，你必须集中精神一会儿。这就激活了你的前额叶皮层，这是大脑中帮助你做决定的部分。它是大脑中帮助你学习新行为的部分。如果你想锁定新习惯，你必须使用大脑的这个部分。而我以前的习惯就是按贪睡按钮，
and avoiding everything. This new habit was about taking action, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1, move before you feel ready. So the countdown is supposed to be, this is how many seconds I have before this thing I'm ruminating about, I have to get out of it. Is that, before it become complacent?
逃避一切。这个新习惯是关于采取行动的，5，4，3，2，1，在感觉准备好之前就动起来。所以倒计时的意思是，这是我在这件我一直在琢磨的事情发生之前仅剩的几秒钟，我必须摆脱它。是这样吗，在它变得麻木之前？
Right, so I have to set this up, so I do this countdown, this final countdown. Oh, sing it will. Go, let's see an illusion. I'll never do it. I'll never do it. Because I don't want to pay for it. Jason, they don't get the reference, which is great.
对，所以我得做好准备，我做这个倒计时，最后的倒计时。哦，唱出来吧，威尔。来吧，让我们见证一个奇迹。我永远不会做。我永远不会做。因为我不想付版权费。杰森，他们听不懂这个梗，不过这很好。
No, but I do. And I love you. And you were fantastic on that show. You should have gotten an Emmy every year, So, so you do, so you, so you're so skinny. So you do the, you do the countdown and the first day it works. Yeah, I get out of bed. I'm like five, fourth, for the first time in six months,
不，但我懂。我爱你。你在那部剧里表现太棒了。你每年都该拿艾美奖的。所以，所以你做，所以你，所以你太瘦了。所以你做倒计时，第一天它就起作用了。对，我起床了。我心想五、四……六个月来头一次，
I was out of bed when the alarm rang. What'd you do? What was the first thing you knocked down? Did you put on, did you put on the Lulu Lemons and you got out there and you just did high, no, no, I walked into the kitchen. Walk. No, no motivation for that yet. I'm just like, I'm low bar here.
闹钟一响我就起床了。你干了什么？你首先攻克了什么？你是不是穿上了露露柠檬，然后冲出去做高——不，不，我走进了厨房。走路。不，还没那个动力呢。我标准放得很低。
We're just talking like, get out of bed. I literally walk into the kitchen and my poor husband. husband standing there in front of the fridge. What are you doing? He lost all that fucking money and he's down there and he's probably making an egg McMuffin. Correct, motherfucker. And so you know how that thing happens
我们只是在说，起床。我literally（字面意义上）走进厨房，我可怜的丈夫正站在冰箱前面。你在干嘛？他亏了那么多该死的钱，他还在那儿，可能在做蛋卷松饼。没错，他妈的。所以你知道那种情况吗？
where you see somebody you love and you just want to kill them? Every day for me. Every day. No, I'm kidding. I love you, Amanda. No, no, no, no. The people that you love the most
你看到你爱的人就想掐死他们？我每天都这样。每天。开玩笑的，我爱你，阿曼达。不，不，不，不。你最爱的人，
are the most annoying. Sure. And so I just went five, four, three, two, one because I knew he was trying his best. It wasn't like he was trying to fail. And my anger wasn't helping. And so counting backwards interrupted that pattern of snapping and screaming and reacting and gave me this ability to be in charge of what I was doing instead of constantly letting my emotions dictate. See, this is what everybody gets wrong
往往最让人恼火。确实。所以我当时就数了5、4、3、2、1，因为我知道他已经尽力了。他并不是故意想失败。我的愤怒也无济于事。所以倒计时打断了那种发飙、尖叫和本能反应的模式，让我能够掌控自己的行为，而不是让情绪一直牵着鼻子走。你看，这就是每个人对动力的误解。
about motivation. Motivation's garbage. It's never there when you need it. You got to learn how to make yourself do things that you don't feel like doing. And if you ever did that, you'd have everything you've ever wanted. And so I'm assuming you put one foot in front of the other, and I'm not asking for a TikTok of the day, but was there, for those out there that are having trouble making this crucial first step, what was the, what really what was the tangible thing that you did first and from that you built on that progress and exponentially put more and more, you know, know, inertia down the road.
动力就是垃圾。当你需要它的时候，它从来不在。你必须学会逼自己去做那些你不想做的事。如果你能做到这一点，你就能拥有一切你想要的东西。所以我猜你迈出了第一步，我不是在要一个今日抖音视频，但对于那些迈出这至关重要第一步有困难的人来说，你做的第一件切实的事情到底是什么？你从那件事开始积累进展，并像滚雪球一样不断积蓄惯性。
It's a great question. Everybody hates the answer. Literally, changing your life isn't glamorous. It's grueling. And it does not happen overnight. It happens over time. And I always say, because people are really like, how did you do everything that you're doing?
这问题问得好。每个人都讨厌这个答案。说实话，改变生活一点也不光鲜亮丽。它是残酷的。而且它不是一夜之间发生的。它是日积月累的。我总是说——因为人们真的很想知道你是怎么做到你现在所做的一切的——
Because that was 16 years ago. And so the person that everybody sees now and what I do out in the world is 16 years in the making. And I say that what you see now is a result of one thing. I taught myself how to get out of bed on days when I didn't fucking. and feel like it. That's the secret. That's it. Because if you can force yourself out of bed when you
因为那是16年前的事了。所以大家现在看到的我和我在世界上的所作所为，是16年积累的成果。我说过，你现在看到的成果源于一件事：我教会了自己在那些他妈的不想动日子里如何起床。这就是秘诀。就是这样。因为如果你能强迫自己起床，即使你
don't feel like it because of the depression or the anxiety or the overwhelm or the hangover or whatever it may be. And the body feeds off that first progress, right? Yes. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Now, Mel, let me ask you this. And I like it. I like this area a lot. And I like the way that you talk about it. I like that your passion for it and your excitement. And I understand and appreciate the way that you were able to do that that first day and see a result and feel a change in your body
因为抑郁、焦虑、不知所措、宿醉或其他任何原因而不想动。身体会从最初的进展中汲取能量，对吧？是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。现在，梅尔，我问你个问题。我很喜欢这个领域。我非常喜欢你谈论它的方式。我喜欢你的热情和兴奋。我理解并赞赏你在第一天能够做到这一点、看到成果并在你的身体、
and in your mind and your spirit, et cetera, all those things connected. And then so you do it again, I imagine. I'm sort of skipping for it. You do it a bunch and you really start to see results. And then you think to yourself, other people can benefit from this too, if I can do it or eventually you get to a point
心灵和精神等各方面感受到改变的方式，所有这些都连结在了一起。然后你又做了一次，我猜。我有点跳跃了。你做了很多次，然后真的开始看到成果。接着你心里想，其他人也可以从中受益，如果我能做到的话，或者最终你达到了一个点，
where you think that other people can benefit from the lessons that you learned, the hard way, etc. But you also have the benefit of this momentum that you've got doing it. So there are other people go, well, yeah, it works for Mel because she's getting feedback from her pushing this out to the world. I don't have, I'm not getting that same feedback on a global level. And I'm not getting that feedback. I'm just, you know, a person in Cleveland who's doing it and nobody's recognizing that I'm doing it. So yeah, it works for you. And you're kicking get ass doing it. You're at the top of the game.
你认为其他人可以从你通过惨痛教训学到的经验中受益，等等。但你同时也享受着你通过行动带来的这种势头。所以其他人就会说，好吧，这对梅尔有用，因为她在把这些推向世界时得到了反馈。我没有，我在全球层面上没有得到同样的反馈。我也没有得到这种反馈，我只是个，你知道的，克利夫兰的一个普通人，没人注意到我在这么做。所以对你管用。而且你干得风生水起，你处于顶峰。
But if you're just Joe Schmoe, like... But 16 years ago, she wasn't getting that, right? It was three years of using it in secret before I ever told anybody about it, because let's face it, I didn't know why it worked. I'm $800,000 in debt. I am barely making
但如果你只是个无名小卒，就像……但16年前她也没有这些，对吧？我在秘密使用它三年后才告诉任何人，因为面对现实吧，我当时根本不知道它为什么管用。我背负着80万美元的债务。我勉强能
the ends meet. What business do I have telling anybody anything? And so I used it in secret. By the way, was that an important part of it, keeping it secret? In other words, holding your power and not bragging to your partner. Hey, Today I'm going to start working out. Like, I find that sometimes my stick-to-itiveness is better
维持生计。我有什么资格去教导任何人？所以我偷偷使用它。顺便问一句，这是一个重要部分吗，把它保密？换句话说，掌控你的力量，而不是向你的伴侣吹嘘。嘿，我今天开始锻炼了。我发现有时候我的坚持不懈会更好，
if I don't share what my goals and my plans for progress are. And I keep it inside and I just do it myself. And I've only got myself to answer to. And then once I get some momentum going, then I share like, hey, by the way, I've been working out for a week, you know, or by the way, I haven't had sugar for a week or something. Jason, do you keep a lot of feelings inside, though. I do.
如果我不分享我的目标和进步计划的话。我把它藏在心里，自己默默去做。我只需要对我自己负责。一旦我取得了一些进展，我才会分享，嘿，顺便说一句，我已经锻炼一个星期了，你知道的，或者顺便说一句，我已经一个星期没吃糖了之类的。杰森，你是不是把很多感情都藏在心里啊。我是。
I know. I know, I know you do. It's going to burst. But was that an important part? Did you, did you, was this a private sort of initial stage? No, like I, like I told Chris, my husband Chris, but I, but literally it was self-preservation. I mean, we were in a free fall for crying out loud. Well, what did Chris say?
我知道。我知道，我知道你会的。都要爆发了。但这真的是个重要部分吗？你，你，这个初始阶段是私密的吗？不，就像我，就像我告诉了克里斯，我丈夫克里斯，但literally（字面意义上）这是一种自我保护。我的意思是，老实说，我们当时正在自由落体。那克里斯怎么说？
Was Chris like, okay, cool. As long as you're not bitching at me and screaming at me, I'll try anything. Like, this keeps you calming off my ass so that I'm working as hard as I'm working as a can woman like finally you see it oh chris now i i mean for chris i know fuck chris okay like come on it's a nice guy your tent taught from 2011 and now has over 30 million views from 2011 and is this is this what it's most was that what it's mostly about is the five second rule no okay so here's the story so three years go by i'm using five four three two one five four three to one to get out of bed to network and get a job to open up the bills to just do the basic blocking and
克里斯是不是觉得，好吧，挺好。只要你别对我唠叨尖叫，我什么都愿意尝试。这让你不再缠着我，好让我像个女人一样尽力工作，最后你终于意识到了。哦，克里斯，不，我是说对于克里斯，我懂，去他妈的克里斯，好吧，拜托，他是个好人。你的TED演讲于2011年发布，现在已经有超过3000万次观看，从2011年开始，这，这就是这一切的核心吗，五秒法则？不，好吧，事情是这样的：三年过去了，我一直在用5、4、3、2、1，5、4、3、2、1来起床、建立人脉、找工作、拆账单，去完成我们所有人都需要做的基础工作，因为没有人会来帮你。你可以坐在这里等着有人来拯救我们。他们不会来的。你越早认识到这一点，你就会明白你必须停止等待准备就绪，你必须让自己的人生到达一个你再也无法忍受现状的境地。所以你得做点改变。所以整整三年，我一直在努力。克里斯重新做回餐饮生意，重新谈判租约，一周工作100个小时。我一份又一份地打零工。我们只想摆脱破产的阴影，带着三个10岁以下的孩子维持生计。你当时literally（字面意义上）只是为了赚张薪水支票。
tackling that we all need to do because nobody's coming. You can sit around and hope that somebody's going to come and fix us. They're not. And the sooner you recognize, you've got to stop waiting to feel ready and you've got to get to a point in your life where where you're at doesn't work for you anymore. So you're going to do something about it. So for three years, I'm just working at it. Chris is going back into the restaurant business, renegotiating leases, like working 100 hours a week. I'm finding an odd job after odd jobs. We can just get the bankruptcy off our back and keep ourselves afloat with three kids under the age of 10. You're literally just looking to make a paycheck.
你在职业生涯上并没有什么宏伟目标。比如，我要建立一个播客，它会取得巨大的成功。不，你当时没有任何方向。完全没有。而且我也觉得，当你把自己的生活彻底搞砸的时候，因为没有人会去做愿景板，然后在上面贴上破产、离婚和酗酒的照片。那是背面。
You're not driving towards some North Star career-wise. Like, I'm going to build a podcast and it's going to be a big success. No, you didn't have any sort of direction. Absolutely not. And also, I think when you get to a point where you really screw up your own life, because nobody makes a vision board and is like, hey, let's put images of bankruptcy and divorce and alcoholism on it. It's on the back.
再加上朋友和家人都在餐饮生意里投资了。所以我总不能到处去诋毁和抱怨。所以我们只能——你当时只想还清债务，在财务上浮出水面。所以我们处于生存模式。当处于生存模式时，你会变得非常不可思议且足智多谋。然后有个老朋友打电话给我，我们当时还背负着80万债务。三年过去了，我们房子上依然有留置权。
And plus friends and family had invested in the restaurant business. And so I can't exactly go around trashing and complaining. And so we're just like- You're looking to pay them back and get your head above water financially. So we're in survival mode. And you're pretty incredible and resourceful when you're in survival mode. And so a buddy calls me, we still have $800,000 in debt. We still have liens on the house three years later.
我们依然在勉强维持生计。我大学时的一个朋友打电话给我说，嘿，旧金山有人在办一场活动，我知道那个人正在找一个经历过多次职业转型的人，我想到了你。这其实不算什么夸奖。但她说，我，你知道的，他们提供两张头等舱机票
We are still just making the ends meet. And a buddy calls me from college and says, hey, there's a person who, who is putting on an event in San Francisco that I know that's looking for somebody who's changed their job a lot and I thought about you. And that's not really a compliment. But she said, I, you know, they're offering two first class plane tickets
我们依然只是勉强维持生计。然后大学的一个哥们给我打电话说，嘿，旧金山有人在筹办一个活动，我知道他们正在找一个频繁换工作的人，我第一个就想到了你。这其实算不上是什么夸奖。但她说，我，你知道的，他们提供两张头等舱机票
and two nights at the St. Regis, all you got to do is talk about career change. Now, I had never given a speech on a stage in my life. I'd taken a public high school speaking class, but I had been a lawyer, a public defender in Manhattan, and so I'd worked in courtrooms, but I'd never given a speech. when you're that in debt,
在瑞吉酒店住两个晚上，你只需要谈谈职业转型。当时我这辈子从来没在舞台上做过演讲。我上过公立高中的演讲课，但我是个律师，在曼哈顿当过公设辩护人，所以我去过法庭，但我从来没有做过演讲。当你背负那么多债务时，
that sounds like a free vacation. Right? And so I'm like, Chris, we're going to San Francisco. Mom, dad, come watch the kids. It sounds like a free vacation in any... Yeah, in any capacity. Yeah. Exactly.
听起来就像是一场免费度假。对吧？所以我就想，克里斯，我们要去旧金山。爸妈，快来帮我们看孩子。听起来就像是一场免费度假……嗯，在任何情况下都是。对。没错。
Well, I didn't really think through the part of 700 people in an auditorium. Right, right, yeah. And so I get out on that stage, and it happens to be one of the first ever TEDx conferences. And they weren't a thing... Where do you get the balls for no stage fright and all that? Oh, you're watching a 21-minute-long panic attack.
嗯，我当时根本没考虑到台下有700人坐在礼堂里。对，对，是的。然后我走上了那个舞台，碰巧那是史上最早的几场TEDx会议之一。当时还没这种东西……你哪来的胆子一点都不怯场？哦，你现在看到的是一个长达21分钟的恐慌发作。
Like, I want you to look close, at that TED talk, I've got this neck rash that people get when they're drunk or they're nervous, a minute in. Oh, yeah, no, I used to get that a ton. I am darting around the stage, and this is not about the five-second rule. It's about career change.
我是说，我想让你仔细看看，在那场TED演讲里，我在开始一分钟后脖子上就长满了那种人在喝醉或紧张时才会起的皮疹。哦，对，没错，我以前经常这样。我在舞台上东奔西跑，而这根本不是什么“五秒法则”，讲的是职业转型。
And I get to minute 19, and I forget how to end the talk. And I look out, and I'm like, oh, I know, I do this thing. I call it the five-second rule. The moment you have an instinct to act, you've got to move within five seconds, or else your brain will kill your motivation.
等我讲到第19分钟时，我突然忘了演讲该怎么结尾了。我放眼望去，然后我想，哦，我知道了，我有个习惯。我把它叫做“五秒法则”。当你产生想要行动的直觉时，你必须在五秒钟内行动起来，否则你的大脑就会扼杀你的动力。
Thank you very much. Oh, by the way, here's my email if you have questions, and I leave. Yeah. Now. You gave your email out publicly? Oh, I mean, I'm just a normal person trying to get a free vacation by giving a speech about something I don't know anything about it. Right. A year goes by.
非常感谢。哦，对了，如果有问题的话，这是我的电子邮箱，然后我就下台了。好吧。现在。你把自己的邮箱公开了？哦，我的意思是，我只是个普通人，想通过就一个我一无所知的话题做演讲来换取一次免费度假。对吧。一年过去了。
Did they pick up incidentals? Sorry. No. A year goes by. Seriously, this is now 2012. A year goes by. I have a job. Chris is still like trying to make.
他们报销杂费吗？抱歉。没有。一年过去了。说真的，现在已经是2012年了。一年过去了。我有了一份工作。克里斯还在努力挣钱。
We still have liens on the house, and TEDx decides to put it online. I don't know this. Another year goes by 2013. I start getting emails at that email address. Wow. People start to write to me from around the world. Mel, I've used 5-4-3-2-1 to lose 100 pounds, 5-4-3-1 to get out of bed despite the depression. I use 5-4-3-2-1 to stop myself from jumping over this ferry and find the courage to ask for help.
我们房子的产权依然被留置，而TEDx决定把它放到网上。我对此一无所知。又过了一年，到了2013年。我开始收到发到那个邮箱里的邮件。哇。世界各地的人开始给我写信。梅尔，我用5-4-3-2-1成功减掉了100磅，用5-4-3-2-1克服抑郁症起床。我用5-4-3-2-1阻止自己跳下这艘渡轮，并找到了寻求帮助的勇气。
And I was so blown away, this answers your question, Will, about like, at one point did you start talking about it, that while working a full-time job for several years, I would come home at night and pour a glass of wine and answer these emails from strangers because I felt obligated to figure out why does this thing work. Right, right. And so I started researching it and talking to people. And simultaneously building a following and a mailing list that you could then sort of transfer over into the podcast? Started to, not yet, like 2012, you can scroll back manually through Instagram, you have to do it manually. All it's, it's just pictures of my kids and barbecues and, you know, I didn't know normal people could make a living giving keynote speeches. And so people started to ask me to speak in 2013, 2014, and like, you know, I went and spoke for free. And then there was this moment in 2014, where 2013, rather, a person came up to me after speaking for free at a big women's conference and
我当时简直惊呆了，这回答了你的问题，威尔，关于你到底是什么时候开始谈论这件事的，那就是在做全职工作的好几年里，我每天晚上回家都会倒上一杯酒，然后回复这些陌生人的邮件，因为我觉得有义务去搞清楚为什么这东西这么管用。对，对。于是我开始研究它并和人们交谈。与此同时，我还积累了一批粉丝和邮件订阅名单，然后你可以把这些转化为播客的听众？开始有了，但当时还没有，比如2012年，你可以在Instagram上一直往回手动翻页，你只能手动翻。上面全都是我孩子的照片、烧烤的照片，你知道的，我以前根本不知道普通人靠做主题演讲就能谋生。所以人们开始邀请我在2013、2014年去演讲，而且，你知道的，我都是免费去讲的。然后在2014年的某个时候，准确地说是2013年，我在一个大型女性大会上免费演讲完后，有一个人走到我面前，
said, hey, did you get your check for this thing yet? And I was like, check? You got paid for this? Am I the only idiot here is doing this for free? And that's what I'm like, I've got to figure this out. Do you think that when you were younger, that this kind of thinking was inside you the whole time when you were growing up, you just didn't know it?
说，嘿，你拿到这次活动的支票了吗？当时我就想，支票？这还能有钱拿？难道只有我这个白痴在免费干活吗？那就是我心想，我必须把这事搞清楚的时候。你觉得当你更年轻的时候，这种思维方式其实一直在你体内，只是你成长过程中并不知道这一点？
Yeah, that's what I wondered too. And like, because I remember your mom used to say, you said, I read that, she said, fix it, wait, wait, fix it yourself and pull up your big girl panty. And figure it out and fix it yourself or something like that. Yep, yep. I think so. You know, I come from like Midwestern farming stock.
对，我也经常这么纳闷。而且，因为我记得你妈以前说过，你说过，我读到过，她说，自己解决，听着，靠自己解决问题，拿出点骨气来。自己想办法解决或者类似这样的话。没错，没错。我想是的。你知道的，我出身于中西部农场家庭。
And so when the chores need to get done, the chores need to get done. Like that's my mom grew up on a big farm. My dad grew up in a working class family. And so there's just sort of a pragmatism to, and a focus on doing things instead of talking about things. Yeah, so that was kind of in you then at the, you know, when you're in. Yeah, and touching bottom often brings out the, the best parts of ourselves. You know, because you need it.
所以当杂务需要完成时，这些杂务就必须得完成。就像我妈妈是在一个大农场长大的。我爸爸在一个工人阶级家庭长大。因此，这其中有一种务实主义，专注于把事情做好，而不是光说不练。好吧，所以这其实已经融入了你骨子里，你知道的，当你……是的，而跌入谷底往往能激发出我们内心最好的一面。你知道的，因为你需要它。
Touching bottoms is completely revolutionized my life. Touching your bottom or touching bottom? Sir, what was the question? No, I do suspect that you do seem to have that, that it's not a, it doesn't feel like a leap. Now, of course, we're catching you after years of doing this and living this way and transforming your life. But I think that there is, I suspect there was a current
跌入谷底彻底改变了我的生活。你是说触底还是碰触你的屁股？先生，请问刚才那个问题是什么？不，我确实怀疑你身上有那种特质，这感觉不像是跨越。当然啦，我们采访你的时候，你已经经历了多年的积累、以这种方式生活并彻底改变了人生。但我认为其中确实有一种潜流，
of that like Sean kind of what you were saying there was a kernel of that in there and whether it's your Midwestern roots or your blue collar I think also you're pretty sharp you know so well yeah you say you're a public defender in New York I mean so you're no ding dong
就像肖恩你刚才说的那种潜流，其中包含着某种核心特质，不管是因为你中西部的根基还是你的蓝领背景，而且我觉得你也很精明，你知道的，所以好吧，你说你以前在纽约当过公设辩护人，也就是说你可不是个笨蛋。
yeah right yeah I guess not I mean I've done some pretty ding dong things no she went to law school for Christ's being smart doesn't mean you're actually smart about how you live your life no but you're no discipline you went through law school like there's there's there's you know how to you know to ask yourself to really bring it if you need to yeah right and you and when you you had ADHD when you were a kid but you didn't know that it was
对，没错，我猜不是吧。不过我也做过不少挺蠢的事。不，看在上帝的份上，她可是上了法学院的。聪明并不意味着你在如何生活这件事上真的很聪明。不，但你很有纪律性，你经历过法学院的历练，你知道如何……你知道如何在需要的时候逼自己一把，对吧。没错，而且你——你小时候患有ADHD，但你当时并不知道那是
ADHD correct yeah but I think sometimes that's that's a superpower later on in life like I just saw this thing like on TikTok or something a long time ago about we talked about this the other day I know I'm against the truth I haven't read that book yet and it said something about like childhood trauma or childhood something sometimes and children create ADD as a coping mechanism they can't leave their house they can't leave where they because that's your shelter
ADHD，对吧？是的，但我认为有时候这在日后的人生中会变成一种超能力。我刚刚在TikTok或什么地方看到过一个很久以前的视频，我们前几天还聊过这个。我知道，我跟那个观点相反，我还没读过那本书。它里面提到过，比如童年创伤或童年的某种经历，有时候孩子们会把ADD当作一种应对机制。他们无法离开自己的家，无法离开他们成长的地方，因为那是他们的庇护所，
and your food and your family and whatever but because of some trauma where you can't leave your brain's trying to constantly constantly constantly figure out how to problem solve and in doing so you develop ADD or ADHD I think there was Gabor Mote that talked about the connection before between Hang on let me finish Gabor Mote
有他们的食物、家庭和各种关爱，但由于某种创伤导致你无法离开，你的大脑就会不断地、不断地、不断地试图弄清楚如何去解决问题，而在这样做的过程中，你就发展出了ADD或ADHD。我想加博·马特之前讨论过这种联系。等一下，让我把话说完，加博·马特，
I think said that yeah go ahead I had a delicious Monte the other day I had a Gimora Latte too last time was in Naples What do you think of that now I will say this, Mel, to that ADHD thing, it sounds like from the little, again, that I know of it,
我想他是这么说的，对吧，请继续。我前几天吃了一个美味的蒙特。我上次在那不勒斯时还喝了一杯吉莫拉拿铁呢。你对这个怎么看？好吧，我得这么说，梅尔，针对那个ADHD的问题，根据我了解的一点点情况来看——
but I know when it comes to people that I'm related to who have been diagnosed with having deficits when it comes to executive function. And I was going to say that earlier, there is that moment of, and it is one of the symptoms of a particular type of ADHD where you know that you have to do it and you can't start it. And that's an executive function deficiency. Yeah, that's interesting. It can also, to Sean's point, it can also be a trauma response, that there's this freeze. Sean's point was so muddled. It was about TikTok and he was like something in someone's saying, something in some time all over the place. The highly intelligent here can track to what Sean's saying.
我知道那些被诊断出执行功能存在缺陷的亲戚们的情况。我刚才就想说这个，那种特定情况会出现的一刻——这也是特定类型ADHD的症状之一，你知道自己必须去做某事，但就是无法开始。这就是执行功能缺陷。对，这很有趣。顺着肖恩的话说，这其实也可能是一种创伤反应，会出现大脑“卡壳”的现象。肖恩刚才说得太含糊不清了。他一会儿扯到TikTok，一会儿又说某人在某个时间说了些什么，乱七八糟的。这里智商高的人才能跟上肖恩的思路。
I think, I think like the demeaning him is a way that you deflected. Thank you, Mel. You're welcome, darn. Well, so to the point on ADHD is super interesting, the majority of women today, because women and men and boys and girls experience ADHD at the exact same level. But women and girls go profoundly underdiagnosed because when it was discovered in the 1970s, they only study boys. and when a boy has 88 yes and so when a boy has this is going to explain marriages this is going to explain your sisters like just buckle up because this is one of those things that every time i explain it people go holy fuck that's me or that's my wife holy and so here's the short backstory so they only study boys and when boys have ADHD which is like a structural thing that's not working in the switching mechanism of your brain you can focus you just have trouble directing it at times.
我觉得，我觉得贬低他其实是你的一种转移话题的方式。谢谢你，梅尔。不客气，真的。好吧，关于ADHD的那个观点非常有趣，如今大多数女性——因为女性、男性、男孩和女孩患ADHD的比例完全相同。但女性和女孩却被严重漏诊了，因为在20世纪70年代发现这种病症时，研究对象全都是男孩。而当一个男孩有……88，对，是的。所以当一个男孩有……这下能解释婚姻问题了，这能解释你姐妹的情况，大家系好安全带，因为这是那种每次我向别人解释时，人们都会忍不住惊呼“操，这不就是我吗”或者“这不就是我老婆吗”的情况。所以简短的背景是这样的：他们只研究了男孩，而当男孩患有ADHD时——这是一种大脑开关机制运作出现问题的结构性问题——你是可以专注的，只是有时很难将注意力导向正确的地方。
Yeah. And so boys are a little bit more fidgety. And you kind of notice it because they're fidgety, they interrupt, they have trouble directing their focus. Girls have the opposite symptoms. They tend to daydream. They get quieter and they get harder on themselves. Now here's what gets interesting and really life-changing for people to learn.
是的。所以男孩会稍微好动一点。你会注意到这一点，因为他们总是坐立不安、打断别人，而且很难控制自己的注意力。而女孩则表现出相反的症状。她们往往会白日做梦。她们会变得更安静，对自己要求也更严格。现在有趣的地方来了，这对人们来说真的是能改变一生的一课。
If you have undiagnosed ADHD or dyslexia or executive functioning, what happens is the primary symptom is you develop anxiety because you are sitting in a classroom or in a setting where you're being asked to do things all day long that your brain can't structurally do right now. And so anxiety develops. So there's a huge generation of women, they call us the lost generation of women that were diagnosed with anxiety in our high school and our college years and then medicated with something to quell the anxiety. But the underlying issue was always undiagnosed ADHD. That's fascinating. Well, it's funny you say that, Mel. So I I had a conversation with my own dad
如果你患有未确诊的ADHD、读写困难或执行功能障碍，其主要症状就是你会产生焦虑。因为你坐在教室里，或者身处一个整天要求你做一些你目前的大脑结构根本无法完成的事情的环境中。于是焦虑就产生了。因此，有一大代女性——被称为“迷失的一代女性”——在高中和大学时期被诊断出患有焦虑症，然后服用药物来压制焦虑。但根本问题其实一直都是未确诊的ADHD。太迷人了。嗯，你这么说挺有意思的，梅尔。所以——我曾和我自己的爸爸聊过这件事，
because I was talking about there was somebody in my family who encountered this and this is within the last three months and I said, you know, when I was a teenager and when I was, you know, a young teenager, especially adolescent in the early 80s, I would get tested a bunch and they say, oh, he's functioning very well.
因为我提到过我家里有人遇到了这种情况，而且这是在过去三个月内发生的。我说，你知道，当我还是个青少年的时候，特别是在80年代初期的青春期，我接受过很多测试，他们说：“哦，他的各项功能都很正常。
We don't understand why he's not doing his work and I was kind of labeled a bad kid. And I said, Dad, you know, and this is something, a conversation I had my dad at almost, I was almost 55 at the time I'm now 55. My dad's 86, and I said, I now recognize in hearing what this doctor said,
我们不明白他为什么不好好完成作业。”我当时差不多被贴上了“坏小孩”的标签。我对爸爸说，你知道的——这是我和爸爸的一次对话，当时我快55岁了，现在我已经55岁了。我爸86岁，我对他说：“在听到这位医生的话后，我发现自己身上也有这种行为。”
this behavior in myself. And I feel like, and of course, you know, you, yeah, what ends up happening is you either get prescribed stuff. I'm talking for a boy, and I can't speak, but, but, or you self-medicating. Yes. And that is one of the, you know, to try to quell the symptoms.
我觉得，当然了，你知道的，结果就是要么给你开一些药——我是针对男孩说的，我无法代表其他人——要么就是你自己去自我治疗。是的。而这也是试图平息这些症状的方法之一。
Is there something one can do for attention deficit that is different than medication? I mean, is there something, is there therapy that one can go through? It's a great question. There's all kinds of things you can do. And I think kind of just understanding the way that your brain works or learns helps you do all kinds of things, whether there's systems for organization, there's certain types of interventions that they do with kids that really help develop. and train. Like our son ended, and this is how I found out at the age of 47 that I was both dyslexic and had ADHD. Wow. The same way that most women do, our kids start struggling in school like
对于注意力缺陷，除了吃药之外，还有没有什么别的方法可以做呢？我的意思是，有什么可以做的吗？有什么疗法可以尝试吗？这是一个好问题。你可以做各种各样的事情。而且我认为，仅仅去理解你的大脑运作或学习的方式，就能帮你做到各种各样的事情，无论是建立组织系统的体系，还是针对孩子们进行某些特定类型的干预，这些确实有助于他们成长和训练。就像我们的儿子最终——这也是为什么我在47岁时才发现自己既有读写困难又有ADHD。哇。跟大多数女性的情况一样，我们的孩子开始在学校遇到困难，就像
you did will. They get labeled a behavioral issue. You then go through all of the neuropsych evaluation testing and then you sit back and go, huh, yeah, that's me. That's me. And I literally turned to my pediatrician and said, you know, Mark, why didn't, like, why, do you think I have ADHD? And he was like, Mel, of course you have ADHD. You're the most ADHD parent I know. I'm like, why didn't you tell me? He's like, I'm not your doctor. Is it something that you inherit from your parents?
你当年那样，威尔。他们被贴上了行为问题的标签。然后你会经历所有神经心理学的评估测试，接着你往后一靠，心想：哈，好吧，确实是我。这就是我。我当时简直是转过头对我的儿科医生说：“你知道吗，马克，为什么——为什么，你觉得我有ADHD吗？”他当时就说：“梅尔，你当然有ADHD。你是我见过ADHD症状最严重的家长了。”我说：“那你以前怎么不告诉我？”他说：“我又不是你的医生。”这是从父母那里遗传来的吗？
They say it can be. They actually say that it can be impacted by what's going on when you're in utero and the stress levels of the parent or the mom and whether or not she's under a lot of stress because it relates to your fight or flight nervous system as well. And it impacts, the way it was explained to me, because again, like everything in life, it's like bad things need to happen. And then I realize, okay, I'm fucked. I got to figure this out. And then I turn it into a research project.
他们说可能是的。他们实际上说过，这可能会受到你在子宫内的情况、父母或母亲的压力水平的影响，以及她是否承受着很大的压力，因为这也与你的“战斗或逃跑”神经系统有关。它会产生影响，正如别人向我解释的那样——因为就像生活中的一切一样，往往是坏事接二连三地发生。然后我意识到：好吧，我完蛋了。我得把这事弄明白。接着我把它变成了一个研究课题。
And then I try to explain what I've learned in the simplest ways. So anybody else, if I can save them the headache and the heartache that I went through for 30, 40 years, not knowing what I was really dealing with, just like you will, not knowing what you're dealing with and self-medicate. and acting out and feeling, you know, hypercritical of yourself. If I can just know what this thing is, that I'm not deficient, I just have a brain that works differently. And with ADHD, I would go to the, you know, you know when you are in college or high school and you're like, all right, I got to study. And you know you can go to the library where you're going to see your friends
然后我试着用最简单的方式解释我学到的东西。这样其他人——如果我能让他们免于经历我曾经历了30、40年的头痛和心痛，那种不知道自己到底在应对什么的心情，就像你一样，威尔，不知道自己在对付什么并靠自我治疗度日，行为失常，还对自己极端苛刻——如果我能弄清楚这到底是什么东西，明白我并不是有缺陷，只是大脑运作方式不同而已。而且有了ADHD，我会去到——你知道，当你上大学或高中时，你会想：好吧，我得去学习了。你知道你可以去图书馆，在那里你会遇到朋友，
or you go to the stacks. And so I would go to the stacks and I'm like, okay, I got to study. And I would sit down and I'd be ready to like lock in and honest to God, I could not for the life of me, just like what you were talking about, Will. I couldn't make myself do it and worse. It's like I could hear the mouse pooping in the corner. I could hear my stomach. And so that mechanism that like an orchestra conductor,
或者你可以去书库。所以我会去书库，心想：好吧，我得学习了。然后我坐下来，准备集中精力，但说实话，我无论如何也做不到，就像你刚才说的，威尔。我就是没办法逼自己去学，更糟糕的是。我甚至能听到老鼠在角落里拉屎的声音。我能听到自己肚子的咕咕声。所以那种机制就像一个乐队指挥，
think about all the input of sound like an orchestra warming up. ADHD, there's this conductor in your brain that's like tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap. Okay, let's bring it all down. Now let's lift up the sound of the strings only. If you don't have that little conductor in your brain, the whole world sounds like an orchestra warming up, and you can't both direct your attention in certain instances, and you can't silence other input. And that's kind of what's happening.
想想各种声音的输入，就像乐队在热身一样。对于ADHD来说，你大脑里有个指挥，一直在那儿：哒、哒、哒、哒、哒、哒、哒。好了，大家把声音轻下来。现在，只把弦乐器的声音放大。如果你大脑里没有那个小指挥，整个世界听起来就像是一个正在热身的乐队，你既无法在某些情况下引导自己的注意力，也无法屏蔽其他声音的输入。这就是正在发生的事情。
That's fascinating. Yeah, it's super fascinating. But there's lots you can do, and it don't have to do medication. Right. So to that point, half of the fix is actually getting the diagnosis, knowing what you have, and it's your choice whether you want to medicate or not. but at least you know what it is is you can start to search for a remedy
太奇妙了。是的，这超级奇妙。但你可以做很多事情，而且不一定非得吃药。好嘞，说到这里，解决问题的一半其实在于确诊，弄清楚你到底有什么毛病，至于你要不要吃药那是你的选择。但至少你知道那是什么了，你就可以开始寻找一种
that might be different than medication or at least just start adjusting your behavior and seeing, trying some different stuff on, yeah? Yeah, and having some grace for yourself. Like, it drives my husband crazy that the faucet's running or that my sink, I don't know what your guys' bathrooms look like, but my husband's sink looks like the sink at a Zen hotel.
可能不同于药物的疗法，或者至少开始调整自己的行为，去尝试一些不同的东西，对吧？是的，并且学会对自己宽容一点。比如，水龙头一直开着或者我的水槽没关，这把我老公快逼疯了——我不知道你们俩的浴室是什么样子的，但我老公的浴室看起来就像禅意酒店里的水槽一样整洁。
Mine looks like you tipped over a Walgreens aisle on top of it. Still? Oh my God, yes. Like I, like, yeah. Wait, so wait, is the cap off the toothpaste for on you all the time? Yeah, kind of. And you have to like rip that knob off, that gets J-B.
我的看起来就像你在它上面打翻了一个沃尔格林药妆店的货架。现在还是这样吗？哦天哪，是的。就像我——就像，是的。等等，所以——牙膏盖是不是经常不盖？对，差不多吧。而且你得把那个旋钮给它狠狠拧下来……
Come on, Mel. Let's get it together. But you know, you know, Mel, I learned all these, like, I learned all these tricks along the way that I would do. And I was saying to, like, telling somebody before that, like, I have like a thing about, like, keys in my wallet and I don't lose it. So I have like a dish, and everywhere I live and everywhere I go, everything goes back in the same spot.
拜托，梅尔。振作一点。不过你知道吗，梅尔，我一路上也学到了所有这些——我学到了很多自己会去做的恶作剧小把戏。我之前跟某个人说过，比如，我对钱包里的钥匙有一套特别的做法，所以我绝对不会把它弄丢。所以，我有专门的小盘子，无论我住在哪里，走到哪里，每样东西都会回到同一个地方。
My bathroom is very clean. And I have taught myself all these things to do these little routines that help keep me. Create order. Yeah, they create order. That's awesome. Because the mind is like this, so the order in the environment helps your mind settle. I love that. And I have one friend he deals with anxiety in this way, and he ends up putting it,
我的浴室非常干净。而且我已经教会了自己做所有这些事情，去建立一些小日常，来帮助自己保持……创造秩序。是的，它们能创造秩序。这太棒了。因为思维就是这样，所以环境中的秩序有助于让你的思绪平静下来。我太喜欢这个了。我有个朋友他就是用这种方式来应对焦虑的，他甚至把
he has a bottle of Xanax and he puts it in the elevator just in case it breaks down. Well, you should actually send him his up. Keeps a bottle in there. No, Will, you should send him this episode. You should send him this episode because the single biggest coping mechanism for anxiety is avoidance. And the more you avoid something, the bigger the anxiety gets. Because when you avoid something, you're telling yourself, I can't handle this. That's what you're doing.
一瓶赞安诺放在电梯里，以防电梯抛锚。好吧，你真该把这一期节目发给他。在里面留一瓶药。不，威尔，你真的应该把这一期节目发给他。你真该把这期节目发给他，因为应对焦虑最大的一种应对机制就是逃避。你越是逃避某件事，焦虑感就会变得越大。因为当你选择逃避时，你其实是在告诉自己：我搞不定这个。这就是你内心在做的事。
So, five, four, three, two, it helps. It's Sean. It's Sean. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Tell us how, is let them a, something that is a cousin to what we're talking about or directly a part of it? It's a, again, great question. So, you know, 5, 4, 321 helps you push through all the resistance, the fear, the hesitation, the anxiety to take the action that changes everything. But I always wonder, why the hell are we so resistant anyway?
所以，五、四、三、二，这很有用。是肖恩。是肖恩。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。请告诉我们，这跟我们刚才讨论的东西是沾亲带故的，还是直接就是其中的一部分？这——又是一个好问题。所以，你知道的，5、4、3、2、1能帮你冲破所有的抗拒、恐惧、犹豫和焦虑，去采取那个能够改变一切的行动。但我总是纳闷，为什么我们总是这么抗拒呢？
Well, it turns out for me anyway, and seems like for millions and millions of people that this book has resonated with, the main source of resistance and fear in our lives is our fear of other people. And the let them theory was something that I discovered, and it has fundamentally changed my life. Like, I feel like I have lived my life backwards for the first 54 years, because I have been consumed by making sure other people are. happy by worrying about their opinions, navigating my day-to-day life based on people's expectations, their moods, what, you know, they want versus truly learning that there's a different way to live. And the let them theory is ultimately a modern version of stoicism, Buddhism, the serenity prayer. It's a book about control and power. What you have control over and what you do not. and two simple words, let them, will free you from the exhausting cycle of trying to manage people's thoughts,
好吧，结果证明——至少对我和千千万万读过这本书并产生共鸣的人来说——我们生活中恐惧和抗拒的主要来源，是我们对其他人的恐惧。而“随他们去理论”是我发现的一个理念，它彻底改变了我的生活。我觉得在前54年里，我的人生完全是倒着过的，因为我被这些事情消耗殆尽：确保别人快乐、担心别人的看法、根据别人的期望、情绪以及他们想要什么来规划我的日常生活，而不是真正去学习一种不同的人生过法。“随他们去理论”归根结底是斯多葛学派、佛教和宁静祷文的现代版。这是一本关于控制力和力量的书。你可以控制什么，以及你不能控制什么。而“随他们去理论”这两个简单的字，将把你从那种试图掌控别人的想法、
their opinions, manage their expectations, there's a better way to live. Let them. Let them think of it. What's the basic tenet of it? Sorry. Is it let them have their judgment? Let them be upset. It's none of my business. Let me just take care of number one. Well, here's yes and. So there's a second part, let me. But the basic tenant will. is that in life, there are only three things you can control. Only three. You can control what you think about. You can control what you do or don't do,
别人的意见、掌控别人期望的精疲力竭的循环中解放出来，有一种更好的生活方式。随他们去。让他们这么想吧。它的基本原则是什么？抱歉。是不是让他们去评判？让他们去生气？这跟我没关系。我只管照顾好自己就行了。嗯，这里是“既要……又要……”。所以还有第二部分：“由我来”。但基本的原则，威尔，
and you can control what you do in response to your emotions. Right. And any psychologist will tell you, when you focus on things you can't control, and the number one thing in life that you will never be able to control is other people, what they say, what they do, what they believe, whether or not they change,
就是在生活中，你只能控制三件事。只有三件。你可以控制自己的想法，你可以控制自己做什么或不做什么，
whether or not they're motivated, whether or not they're anxious, whether or not they get sober. You can't control other people, and yet we exhaust ourselves and waste so much time and energy, allowing meaningless shit and other people's stuff to drain your most precious resource. Well, Mel, and part of that, too, is you also can't control, I can't, there's not enough time for me to go around
并且你可以控制自己对情绪做出的反应。没错。任何心理学家都会告诉你，当你把注意力集中在你无法控制的事情上时——而人生中你永远无法控制的第一件事就是其他人，他们说什么、他们做什么、他们信仰什么、他们是否改变、
and everybody I meet and tell them how they need to treat me as well. that's kind of part of it for me. That's interesting. And I was talking about this morning with some people. I was saying, we've talked about it on here before. Part of that also for me is, and it's people and it's things, I can't be at the effect of circumstances. Because I got to make my own weather, in a sense.
他们是否有动力、他们是否焦虑、他们是否戒酒了——你是无法控制其他人的，然而我们却精疲力竭，把大量的时间和精力浪费在允许那些毫无意义的烂事和别人的闲事来榨干你最宝贵的资源上。好吧，梅尔，其中一部分原因还在于，你同样无法控制——我做不到，我没有足够的时间去到处
Because if I'm at the effective circumstances, man, that's tough sledding. That is really tough sledding. Do you know what I mean? So are you talking about, like, if you're in your car and, traffic builds up, and for most people, they're going to grip the wheel and get pissed off about the traffic. And the truth is, you can't actually control the traffic. Yeah. And so why would you allow something like that to drain your time and energy? 100%. And I'll take it a step further, and this is sometimes where I lose people.
见我遇到的每个人，并告诉他们应该如何对待我。对我和我而言，这其实也是其中的一部分。这很有趣。我今天早上还跟一些人讨论过这件事。我说过，我们以前在这里也讨论过。对我来说，其中一部分原因——既关乎人也关乎事物——是我不能受制于环境。因为从某种意义上说，我必须自己去创造好天气。
I'll say, when there's a lot of traffic, and you've come a long way, and then people are trying to get in, and you're like, and most people are like, fuck you, I've been waiting for a mile. I'm not going to let you in. And if you let people in, I guarantee you traffic will open up for you. It works for me every time. The more I give it away, the more I go ahead, go ahead. It works every time. It's the craziest thing.
因为如果我受制于环境，天哪，那日子可太难熬了。那真的太艰难了。你知道我的意思吗？所以你是说，比如当你坐在车里遇到堵车时，大多数人都会紧紧抓住方向盘，然后对交通状况气急败坏。但事实是，你实际上根本无法控制交通状况。没错。所以你为什么允许这种事情来耗费你的时间和精力呢？百分之百。我还要再深入一步，有时候我会在这一点上失去听众。
I don't know what to tell you. It's not just the traffic opens up. Something opens up inside you. You recognize. Well, that's getting to love. And then that works with love too. It does, but it's something else first because most of us are really selfish. And when we say let them, let them in.
我会说，当交通非常拥堵，你已经开了很长一段路，然后有人试图强行并线时，大多数人的反应都是：去你的吧，我已经等了一英里了。我才不让你并线呢。而如果你让别人并线，我向我妈保证，交通就会为你敞开。这每次对我都管用。我越是懂得给予，越是说“请便，请便”，它就每次都管用。这简直是最疯狂的事了。
traffic's either going to open up or it's not. And I do believe what you believe that it does start to shift things, but what it shifts first is you recognize that your energy and your time is worse something. And when you start to value and protect your time and energy
我不知道该怎么跟你说。不仅交通会畅通无阻。你内心深处某种东西也会豁然开朗。你意识到——好吧，这就上升到爱了。而且这在爱里面也管用。确实如此，但首先是别的东西，因为我们大多数人都非常自私。当我们说“随他们去”时，让他们并线吧，
from people's expectations, people's moods, people's rude behavior, traffic, long lines, you value and have more time and energy. You become more in control and more empowered as a human being and then everything starts to change because you're not at the effect
交通要么会疏通，要么不会。而且我确实相信你的看法，它确实开始改变一些事情，但它首先改变的是让你认识到你的精力和时间是有价值的。当你开始重视并保护自己的时间和精力，
of all the shit going on outside of you. That's right. And, yes, and if I'm stingy with my attention, with my love, with my kindness, I will get stinginess from the universe in return. That is a lock for me anyway. And I think
不被别人的期望、别人的情绪、别人的粗鲁行为、交通堵塞、长长的队伍所左右时，你就会更加珍视并拥有更多的时间和精力。你作为一个人会变得更有控制力、更有力量，然后一切都开始改变，因为你不再受制于
that feeling of feeling unloved is generally because I'm not pushing out enough. And that, anyway, sorry. No, go ahead. Well, I didn't mean to cut you. Sean, what was your question? No, Sean.
发生在你身边的所有破事。没错。而且，是的，如果我对自己的注意力、对我的爱、对我的善良感到吝啬，宇宙也会反过来对我吝啬。不管怎样，对我来说这绝对是板上钉钉的。而且我认为
Went to, any theater stories? Let him, Sean. Let him. Go ahead. What was your question, Sean? She did give you a good one up there on stage. Didn't know how to end it. She gave you a great theater story.
那种感到不被爱的情绪，通常是因为我付出的爱还不够。总之，对不起。不，你请说。好吧，我不是故意打断你的。肖恩，你的问题是什么？不，肖恩。
What do you do, Mel, as far as let them go in this world that we live in about social media and comments and people coming at you with, what's that? Nothing. Let him. Sounds great. No, I was going to say, with people, like for you, I'm sure you get all kinds of comments, and I know people, other people, they get, you know, comments that they can't, they thrive on the positive comments and they, you know, lose themselves on the negative ones. So what about let them for those?
说到这儿，有什么剧场的故事吗？随他去吧，肖恩。随他去。请说，肖恩，你的问题是什么？她在台上面对你的时候确实出了个好招。不知道怎么收场。她给你讲了个极好的剧场故事。
And for yourself, by the way, for yourself. Well, you can never control what somebody else thinks, Sean. Right. So let them think what they're going to think. Let them not like you. I just wanted to put that out there. No, no, I mean that. It's what's destroying a lot of society today
梅尔，在我们生活的这个时代，面对社交媒体、评论区以及向你涌来的各种言论时，你是怎么做到“随他们去”的？那是啥？没什么。随他们去。听起来挺好。不，我本来想说的是，面对各种人——比如对你而言，我确信你会收到各种各样的评论，我也知道其他人会收到……你知道的，那些他们无法承受的评论。他们靠正面的评论汲取养分，却在负面的评论里迷失了自我。那么，对于这些评论，该怎么应用“随他们去”呢？
or people actually put weight into what people say about them and to them on social media and everywhere else. It goes even more than that, Sean, because let's just unpack this. Let's say that you are pulling out Instagram and you're about to post something and you pick a photo and you're like, oh, not that photo. And then you put the filter on it
顺便问一句，对你自己也是如此。好吧，你永远无法控制别人的想法，肖恩。没错。所以随他们怎么想好了。随他们不喜欢你好了。我只是想把话挑明了说。不，不，我是认真的。这是正在摧毁当今社会的很大一部分东西，
and then you go to write the caption and then you put the emoji and then you backspace. You're thinking, is this too much? Is this for whom? Before you even, express yourself, you're already jumping into the brain of another human being and trying to anticipate what they're going to think. And here's the truth. There is nothing you can post that will actually guarantee somebody has a positive or negative thought because you can't control
或者说人们太把别人在社交媒体和其他地方对他们说的话当回事了。甚至不仅于此，肖恩，让我们来剖析一下。假设你正打开Instagram，准备发点东西，你挑了一张照片，然后心想：哦，这张照片不行。接着你给它加了滤镜，
it. Yeah. And even if you could, you can't get them all. Yeah, just let them do what they're going to do. Let them unfollow me. Let them misunderstand. Let them be disappointed. Let them let them let go, Mel. Here come the dick picks. Yeah, let them. Let them. I don't have to look at it. Let me decide what I'm going to look at. go. I'll take them, let them. The poor interns that are now in the DMs, thanks, well.
然后去写配文，接着加上表情符号，然后又按了退格键。你在想：这样会不会太过了？这是给谁看的？在你甚至还没有表达自我之前，你就已经一头扎进另一个人类的大脑里，试图去预测他们的想法了。而事实是：没有什么东西是你发出去就能保证别人一定会有正面或负面看法的，因为你根本无法控制。
That's so funny. Okay, so wait, I got some good stuff here. Wait. Oh, what's the most shocking coaching request you've ever received? Because you do private coaching too. Oh, I don't do any private coaching. Oh, I thought you did.
没错。而且就算你能，你也抓不完所有人。没错，随他们去折腾吧。随他们取消关注我好了。随他们误解好了。随他们失望好了。随他们去吧，让这一切过去吧，梅尔。那些色情照片要来了。对，随他们去。随他们发好了。我又不用看。由我来决定我要看什么。走开。我全收下，随他们去吧。现在私信里那些实习生可惨了，谢谢你，威尔。
I thought you did one-on-one coaching with, like, wealthy people. No, no, no, no, no. Don't have time for that anymore. But the most shocking request, well, I got a request. None of them are shocking. Yeah. They really aren't because when it's not you, it's easy to give people advice
太搞笑了。好吧，等等，我这里有些好东西。等等。哦，你收到过最令人震惊的教练指导请求是什么？因为你做私人指导。哦，我根本不做私人指导。哦，我以为你做呢。
because you're not emotionally attached to what's happening. And if you listen closely to anybody, you can really tell what they're grappling with. And what most of us are grappling with is either the fear of disappointing somebody. Yeah. Or the fear that if you do this thing, somehow people are going to judge you and you're going to end up alone. Right. And so everything comes back down to. this fear of what other people are going to think about you and how their actions dictate your
我以为你给那种有钱人做一对一的指导呢。不，不，不，不，不。我可没那闲工夫了。不过要说最令人震惊的请求嘛……其实没一个令人震惊的。真的没有，因为当事情不发生在你身上时，给别人提建议是件很容易的事，
value. And here's the secret. The secret is you have to like you. And you will only like yourself if you can learn how to let other people be unhappy and learn how to let people be disappointed and let people have their opinions and let me really be clear about the decisions that make me proud of myself because when you're proud of yourself you kind of don't give a shit what other people are. So for a lot of people that are fans of yours or people that read your books
因为你对发生的事情没有情感依附。如果你仔细倾听任何人，你就能真正听出他们在纠结什么。而我们大多数人在纠结的，要么是害怕让别人失望。是的。要么是害怕如果你做了这件事，不知怎么的别人就会评判你，最后落得孤身一人的下场。没错。所以一切都归结于——
or whatever, you know you come off as this fearless you have fearlessness and confidence and so you must have some self-doubt about something. Every day. I was literally sitting here going, am I going to have a moment where I kind of
对别人怎么看你的恐惧，以及他们的行为如何决定了你的价值。而这里的秘密在于：你必须喜欢你自己。只有当你学会如何接受别人对你不满、学会如何接受别人会失望、学会允许别人有自己的观点，并且真正明确那些能让自己感到骄傲的决定时，你才会真正喜欢自己。因为当你为你自己感到骄傲时，你其实根本不在乎别人怎么看你。所以对于许多你的粉丝或读过你书的人来说，
have an accident in my pants like Jason did in the green room? You know, Colbert. Oh, that's a great callback. Because I'm so nervous about meeting these guys. Like, I literally, yeah, well, actually, you and I are going to be on Jimmy Fallon on the 17th of September. And I'm sorting through your garbage to see if you've hidden underwear in there under a Diet Coke can. Get the D.C. out of the way, man.
不管怎样，你给人的印象是一个无所畏惧的人，你拥有无畏和自信，所以你肯定也会对某些事情产生自我怀疑。每天都有。我刚才就坐在那儿想：我是不是一会儿要像杰森在化妆间里那样，突然大小便失禁啊？你知道的，科尔伯特。哦，这个梗接得太棒了。因为我见这些人紧张得要命。就像，我 literalmente，好吧，实际上，你和我将在9月17日上吉米·法伦的节目。我在翻你的垃圾桶，看看你是不是把内衣藏在健怡可乐罐下面了。把健怡可乐拿开，老兄。
I can't wait to meet you. Well, I was going to ask this same question. Like, are you enjoying that your state of confidence and sort of leaning forward? and the things actually creates the privilege of new anxieties. As you reach and hurdle forward, you're now seeing a whole new level of complexities and challenges that are a result of you leaning forward and breaking through. In the open, too, like to a broader audience.
我等不及要见你了。好吧，我本来想问同一个问题。比如说，你是否很享受你现在的自信状态以及那种勇往直前的姿态，而这些其实为你带来了新的焦虑作为特权？当你不断向前突破和跨越时，你现在看到了一个全新的、更加复杂的层面和挑战，而这正是你勇往直前、实现突破的结果。而且是在光天化日之下，面对更广泛的受众。
You know, I'm really grateful that all this happened later in life. Yeah. I really am because, you know, when you go through an experience where you literally almost lose everything that matters to you, whether that's your marriage or your family or your home or your sanity. Or in your case, all of it, right? Yeah, all of it. And being a parent, I mean, that must have ratcheted it up, too,
你知道的，我真的很庆幸这一切发生在生命的晚期。是的。我是认真的，因为当你经历过那种几乎失去所有对你重要的人或事——无论是你的婚姻、家庭、家园还是你的理智——的体验时。或者对你来说，是失去了一切，对吧？是的，一切都失去了。而且作为父母，我的意思是，那一定让情况更糟糕了，
worried about the welfare of your kids. Oh, my God. I can't imagine. Our kids would come downstairs at night after Chris and I had been fighting and screaming at each other, and they would find us collapsed in chairs, like, hung over. Yeah. That's how they, like, you know you're,
担心孩子们的安危。哦，天哪。我简直无法想象。每当克里斯和我吵完架、冲对方大吼大叫之后，我们的孩子们会在深夜走下楼来，然后发现我们像宿醉一样瘫倒在椅子上。是的。那就是他们的生活方式——
not winning at the parenting game when your kids wake you up so they can catch the bus. It was not good. And so all of this that you see now, whether it's the massive scale of the podcast or the number one book,
当你孩子们还得把你叫醒以便让他们赶上校车时，你就知道自己在育儿这场游戏里彻底失败了。那感觉真糟。所以你现在看到的这一切，无论是规模庞大的播客还是畅销书，
I mean, this book is on track to be the most successful nonfiction book ever launched. Six million copies in six months. Amazing. Wow. That's amazing. And part of it is because I'm just reminding you guys of what you know to be true. Excoicism is not a new idea.
我的意思是，这本书有望成为有史以来最成功的非虚构新书发布。六个月内售出六百万册。惊人。哇。太惊人了。部分原因是因为我只是在提醒你们那些你们本来就知道是真理的事情。斯多葛学派并不是什么新概念。
Victor Frankl, man's search for meaning. What's happening out there is not where the power is. Your power is in your response to it. But these are all intellectual ideas. What I love about saying let them and then let me, which is let them is where you release the control over something you can't control, and let me is where you take the power back and focus on what you can control, which is your response to what's happening.
维克托·弗兰克的《人的意义寻找》。外界发生的事情并不是力量的所在。你的力量在于你对它的反应。但这些都只是理智上的概念。我喜欢“随他们去”和“由我来”的原因在于，“随他们去”意味着你放弃了对你无法控制的事情的控制权，“由我来”则意味着你夺回了力量，并将注意力集中在你能够控制的事情上，也就是你对正在发生的事情的反应。
This is just a tool, but it reminds people of what they need. know to be true since the beginning of time. And what I'm grateful for is that having almost lost everything I care about and having just clawed my way out of debt and built this just brick by brick over the last 16 years, I have stayed laser focus on what really matters. I live in the middle of nowhere in Vermont. I have no interest in the bigness aspect of all of it, because you guys know, the second something hits, everybody thinks they know what you should do next. Everybody sees something bigger for you. I would like more time with my husband and my kids.
这只是一种工具，但它提醒了人们自古以来就应该知道的真理。而我感到庆幸的是，在几乎失去了我所关心的一切、在过去16年里靠着一砖一瓦拼命摆脱债务并建立起这一切之后，我依然对真正重要的事情保持着高度的专注。我住在佛蒙特州一个人烟稀少的地方，我对这一切宏大的场面毫无兴趣，因为你们也知道，一旦某件事火了，每个人都觉得他们知道你接下来该做什么。每个人都为你设想了更宏大的前景。我只想和我的丈夫以及孩子们有更多的时间相处。
I would like to enjoy some of this success, meaning I'm not actually working all the time. And so for me, I think the anxiety or the issues that I face is more around just saying no and letting people have their expectations about what the podcast should become or what I should do next and staying laser focused, not on up here, but on what's right in front of me right now. Because if you lose sight of what got you to where you are, you basically blow up everything you created. And so I am staying very focused on waking up every day
我想享受一部分成功带来的成果，这意味着我其实并不是每时每刻都在工作。所以对我来说，我认为我所面对的焦虑或问题，更多是关于如何学会说“不”，如何允许别人对播客应该变成什么样或我接下来应该做什么抱有他们自己的期望，并且保持高度专注——不是关注那些虚浮的名利，而是关注此时此刻就摆在我眼前的实事。因为如果你忽视了是什么让你走到了今天，你基本上就把你所创造的一切都给毁了。所以我将非常专注于每天醒来时
and just making decisions that make me feel proud of myself and doing the best that I can and giving people a little bit of grace and focusing on what I can control and what I can't. And then the rest will take care of it, you know. I love that. What's the single thing that people think will make them happy, but won't? In your opinion. I think the single thing that people think will make them happy that doesn't is achieving the thing. There's so much research that, you know, when you get the
做出让我自己感到骄傲的决定，尽我所能做到最好，对人们多一点包容，专注于我能控制的事情和不能控制的事情。然后剩下的就顺其自然了，你知道的。我太喜欢这个了。在你看来，人们认为会让他们快乐但实际上不会的一件事是什么？我认为人们以为会让他们快乐但实际上不会的那件事，就是达成目标本身。有很多研究表明，你知道，当你得到了
million dollars, you're going to be happy. When you win the race, when you get the person, it's the pursuit of it. Everybody needs something that gets you out of bed. Everybody needs something that you're excited about, whether it's video games or it's birdwatching or it's volunteering. If you don't have something that you're pursuing
一百万美元，你会开心的。当你赢得比赛，当你得到那个人的时候，其实是追求的过程。每个人都需要能让你离开床的东西。每个人都需要让你感到兴奋的东西，不管是电子视频游戏、观鸟还是做志愿服务。如果你没有在追求某种
that's bigger than you, then you're always going to be stuck in that sort of survival autopilot, same old, same old moment. You've got to give yourself an opportunity to get proud of yourself, as you said earlier, and that's usually a pursuit of something.
比你更宏大的东西，那么你就会一直陷入那种生存的自动驾驶模式，日复一日，千篇一律的时刻。你必须给自己一个机会去为你自己感到骄傲，正如你刚才所说，这通常是对某种事物的追求。
Yeah, but I think that for me, I would imagine, I would suggest that part of that is a spirit, spiritual experience. Very much so. And I think that that's the true. It's funny, I was watching sort of...
是的，但我认为对我来说，我会想象，我会建议其中一部分是一种精神上的体验。确实如此。我认为这就是真相。很有意思，我当时在看某种……
Love Island? Yeah, have you seen it? It's the episode you're on, Jason. Yeah. No, it was the few days leading up to the Open, the British Open the Gulf, and Scotty Schaeffler gave this press conference
《爱情岛》？对，你看过吗？就是你上那一集，杰森。对。不，那是英国公开赛、英国高尔夫公开赛前的几天，斯科蒂·舍夫勒召开了这场新闻发布会
that I found to be fascinating. And he's being asked all these questions in world number one. He has been dominating golf. the last couple of years and he gave this answer and the room was silent and he sort of said part of me thinks i spent all my life to win these tournaments to win this tournament the bair nelson in his home in my hometown to have a few minutes of like yeah and then i realized what's the point and he went and he went on from there and i found it absolutely fascinating and i go here is a guy
我发现这非常吸引人。当时他作为世界第一被问到各种问题。他在过去几年里一直统治着高尔夫球坛，他给出了这样一个回答，房间里鸦雀无声，他大概是说，我一部分心想，我一生都在努力赢得这些比赛，在家乡赢得这场比赛——拜恩·尼尔森赛，然后享受几分钟的那种“耶”，接着我意识到，这有什么意义呢？他接着往下说，我发现这绝对太吸引人了，我想这里有一个人
who is at this crossroads and he's having this deep and almost spiritual experience where he's realizing that there's got to be he's looking for perspective he's gaining it and he's looking for more you know our buddy rob meter all this jokes perspective is a really hard thing to get if you don't have it and and hearing him that hearing this guy who's at the top of the i mean the millions of dollars saying like now what well yeah and he's and he's saying and why and he actually said a few times jb he said what's the point and it was and honestly it was chilling almost listening to him and he wasn't poor me
正处于这个十字路口，他正在经历一次深刻的、近乎精神上的体验，他意识到必须有——他在寻找视角，他正在获得视角，他还在寻找更多，你知道的，我们的好友罗伯·米特尔总是开玩笑说，如果你没有视角，视角真的是一件很难得到的东西。听他这么说，听这个处于顶峰的人——我是说拥有数百万美元的人说“现在怎么办”——好吧，是的，他在说，为什么？他甚至好几次说，JB，他说“这有什么意义”，而且老实说，听着他说话几乎让人毛骨悚然，他并不是在怨天尤人
and he was very happy for all the success and he felt he was very grateful rather and yet at the same time he could see that he was struggling with that idea and there's something really really fascinating about that to me. Mel, this has been a blast. You are brilliant.
他为所有的成功感到非常高兴，或者说他感到非常感激，然而与此同时，你能看出他在与那种想法作斗争，对我来说，这其中有些非常非常吸引人的地方。梅尔，这次聊得太开心了。你太出色了。
We've taken up way too much of your time. Brilliant, brilliant. And look, you have a whole studio behind you and you stopped to talk to us about it. Yeah, it's above my garage in Vermont. That's this one. We've got to have you always come to Boston. Although you don't go anywhere.
我们占用了你太多时间了。太出色了，太出色了。你看，你身后整个都是一个演播室，而你停下来和我们聊这些。对，它在佛蒙特州我车库的上面。就是这个。我们一定要让你来波士顿。虽然你哪儿也不去。
We got you guys do stuff. If you ever want to, you have an open invitation to the Mel Robbins podcast. Thank you. Oh, man. I mean it. I'd love to have you on.
我们有，你们做那些节目。如果你愿意的话，梅尔·罗宾斯播客永远向你发出诚挚邀请。谢谢。哦，天哪。我是认真的。我很乐意邀请你来。
Pick you apart on live camera. This would be amazing. No, I'm just kidding. No, I do. I'm really looking forward to meeting you on the 17th. That'll be awesome. I'm looking forward to meeting you too.
在直播镜头前把你解构一番。这太棒了。不，我开玩笑的。不，我是说真的。我真的很期待17号见到你。那一定很棒。我也很期待见到你。
Thank you, Sean, for selecting me. I literally was so moved, and I can tell you the cheeseball thing now because I hate it when people come on and gush and fan. But you caused so many problems in my marriage, you guys, because when I first started listening to you like everybody did, I would come home because I was so jealous of your friend group. And I thought, why are my friends boring?
谢谢你，肖恩，选中了我。我真的非常感动，现在我可以把那个土里土气的秘密告诉你了，因为我很讨厌别人上节目时表现得像个狂热粉丝一样阿谀奉承。但是你们在我的婚姻里制造了好多问题，伙计们，因为我刚开始像所有人一样听你们的节目时，我会回家，因为我太嫉妒你们的朋友圈了。我在想，为什么我的朋友们这么无聊？
And I would come home to my husband be like, you need to start picking on me. We're not interesting enough. And it turns out picking on your spouse is not a great thing for a match. You've got to let them be who they are, right? It's our love language. It's our love language. I love that.
然后我回到家里对丈夫说，你需要开始挑我毛病。我们不够有趣。结果证明，挑剔你的配偶对于一段亲密关系来说并不是件好事。你必须让他们做他们自己，对吧？这是我们的爱的语言。这是我们的爱的语言。我太喜欢这个了。
And thank you for allowing us as your listeners to feel like we are part of this friend group because to have a friend group where you can really see that you guys love each other deeply and still jab at each other. It is a very rare thing and it's a gift to experience it in our lives to listen to you guys that way. So thank you for welcoming us in. Well, thank you for saying that. And truly, truly, thank you for coming on this podcast. You're a very big deal.
谢谢你们允许我们作为听众觉得我们也是这个朋友圈的一部分，因为能拥有这样一个朋友圈——在这里你真的能看到你们深爱着彼此，却又依然互相调侃，这是一件非常罕见的事情，能以这种方式听你们聊天，是我们生命中的一份礼物。所以谢谢你们欢迎我们加入。哦，谢谢你这么说。真的，真的，谢谢你来参加这个播客。你可是个了不起的大人物。
I know, I wish this was two hours. I feel like I've learned a lot. I know, right? Well, maybe we can open up those private sessions. You know? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm going to DM you for a one-on-one. Just a dick pick, okay?
我知道，我真希望这是两个小时。我觉得我学到了很多。我知道，对吧？嗯，也许我们可以开放那些私密咨询。你知道的？对，对，对。我要私信你求个一对一。只要一张丁丁照，好吗？
You'll know who it's from, that's for sure. Thanks, Mel. I appreciate it. Thank you, Mel. Thank you, Mel. Thank you, Mel. Thanks, guys. Bye, yeah.
你肯定知道是谁发来的，那是当然。谢谢你，梅尔。我很感激。谢谢你，梅尔。谢谢你，梅尔。谢谢你，梅尔。谢谢你们。拜，拜。
See you later. Bye, bye. Bye. what a pleasure that was awesome absolutely yeah she literally was just talking about her the other day that's amazing yeah she's been on my list for like you know a couple years now but she um you know six over six million copies in that book let them i mean it's amazing and it's also amazing when people like her or for you know another example to be Oprah or these people who lend their brains you know to the masses for what they've learned or discovered and they pass it on to other
再见。拜，拜。拜。真是一大乐事，太棒了，绝对是的，她刚才还字面意思上在谈论她呢，这太神奇了。是的，她在我（采访）的名单上呆了大概好几年了吧，但她……你知道的，那本书卖了六百多万册，《让他们去吧》，我的意思是这太棒了。而且当像她这样的人——或者另一个例子比如奥普拉，或者这些将他们的智慧贡献给大众，分享他们所学所发现的知识的人——传递给其他
people hopefully hoping they can help other people too i love that kind of stuff kind of like if i can do it you can do it kind of thing yeah what a gift um that she's as a result of her own personal circumstance you know and touching bottom as she was saying you know and and developing these these coping skills out of out of necessity and desperation that she found herself with a vehicle to share all of that knowledge and enlightenment with with so many millions of people and uh obviously has helped and so many folks, what a great use of your life, right? We're all going to look back when we're old and gray
人时，也希望他们能帮助到其他人，我太喜欢这种类型的节目了。有点像是“如果我能做到，你也能做到”那种感觉。是的，这真是个天赋。她由于自己的个人境遇，正如她所说的那样跌入谷底，出于必要和绝望发展出了这些应对技能，她发现自己拥有了一个能够与数百万民众分享所有这些知识和启示的平台，而且显然已经帮助了这么多人，这真是对生命的绝佳利用，对吧？我们等老态龙钟的时候回首往事
and did we use our years right. And what a great success way. And you listen to her talk and it's kind of like, oh, yeah, well, that makes, how did I not know that? It's like all common sense, basically. Yeah, well, oftentimes. Yeah, I mean, I think we all have some coping skills in us but maybe they're just sort of dormant
就会想我们是否正确利用了我们的岁月。这真是一种巨大的成功方式。你听她讲话，就会觉得，哦，对啊，这很合逻辑，我怎么会不知道呢？这基本上都是常识。是的，通常是这样。是的，我的意思是，我觉得我们每个人身上都有一些应对技能，但它们可能只是处于休眠状态
until you hear somebody put them to words and you go, oh, somebody just articulated what I kind of feel in me but didn't know if I was allowed to kind of use it. And somebody kind of puts it into words and puts it in somewhat of a scientific form. You're like, oh, great, yeah, let's use that. Yeah, for sure, for sure. Guys, can I share some?
直到你听到有人把它们用语言表达出来，你会想，哦，有人刚刚把我内心那种感觉阐述出来了，但我不知道自己是否被允许去使用它。然后有人把它组织成语言，并以某种科学的形式表达出来。你会想，太棒了，是的，我们就用那个吧。是的，绝对的，绝对的。伙计们，我能分享一些吗？
Oh, boy. Can I share some British words I've learned while I'm here? Sure. I guess so. I mean, how much of a choice do we have? Not much. It's going to take 30 seconds. So we have a dad joke before you get into your body?
哦，天哪。我能分享一些我在这里学到的英国词汇吗？当然。我想可以吧。我的意思是，我们有多大选择余地？没多少。这只需要30秒。所以在你进入你的身体……
section. There you want one. Yeah. Oh, I like it. We've got a book listener. Don't rifle through. Just stick your finger on a certain page. Yeah.
环节之前，我们先来个冷笑话吗？你想来一个。好的。哦，我喜欢。我们有个书迷听众。别翻来翻去了。就把手指按在某一页上。对。
Here it comes. A good elevator joke works on so many levels. Great. Love it. Very nice. Love it. Thank you. And into our buy section now.
来了。一个好的电梯笑话可以在多个层面（楼层）起作用。太棒了。喜欢。非常好。喜欢。谢谢。现在进入我们的“买”环节。
And now it's pre. Speaking of that, these are the three things I've heard. You take the lift, I'll take the apples and pears. I didn't know apples and pears meant stairs that's cockney right it's cockney yeah the way they do that i don't know and then if somebody calls you give me a call on my dog and bone i got a call on my dog and bone i didn't know phone was dog and bone it seems like you're saying five words instead of one i don't really get it but go ahead
现在是预告。说到这个，这是我听到的三个词。你乘电梯（lift），我走楼梯（apples and pears）。我不知道苹果和梨（apples and pears）代表楼梯，那是伦敦方言对吧？是伦敦方言，他们那种说话方式，我不太懂。然后如果有人叫你，用我的狗和骨头（dog and bone）给我打个电话。我用狗和骨头接到了一个电话，我不知道电话就是狗和骨头，这感觉你明明可以用一个词非要说五个词，我实在搞不懂，不过你继续
that's right and then the last one somebody brought in this is this is a true story somebody brought in bagels the other day for at rehearsal for a good night oscar at the i can't wait look who's back He's just in the band. Just when you thought he went away, he's the bag. Look who's back. Anyway, so he brought these bagels from a store, and this is the truth. And the way they spelled bagel was B-E-I-G-E-L.
没错，然后最后一个，有人带了——这是一个真实的故事——有人在《晚安，奥斯卡》排练时带了贝果（bagels）来，我等不及了，看谁回来了。他就在乐队里。就在你以为他走了的时候，他又回来了。看谁回来了。不管怎样，他从一家店里买来了这些贝果，千真万确。他们拼写贝果的方式是 B-E-I-G-E-L。
And that was the brand name. Huh. And how would you pronounce that? Yeah, how would you pronounce it? I think it's, yeah, I think it pronounced it. B-E-I-G-E-L-E. Beigel. Would you like a dozen bagel?
那是品牌名称。哈。你会怎么发音呢？是的，你会怎么读它？我觉得是，是的，我觉得发音是。B-E-I-G-E-L-E。贝格尔（Beigel）。你想要一打贝格尔吗？
Would you like a bagel? Would you like bagel? Smartless. Smart. Yes. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry,
你想要一个贝格尔吗？你想要贝格尔吗？Smartless。聪明。是的。Smartless 是百分之百有机且由班尼特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）
and Rob Armjarf. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及罗勃·阿尔姆贾夫（Rob Armjarf）手工制作的。Smartless。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。